construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres je pense que ces
gens de projets qui se fait pas tout
seul dans son coin on est dans un truc
vraiment de coopération de partage de
partage
non
en direct ce navire est très simple mais
c'est pas du tout le cas
en réalité le vrai maître c'est l'ours
blanc est en 2d le brise glace
nous avons entrepris une mission unique
peut être la première de ce type dans
l'histoire de la marine russe
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur rt
france pour deux heures d'émission nous
décryptons comme chaque soir du lundi au
jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau et nos reporters sur
le terrain tout de suite les titres de
ce mercredi 26 février 2020 dix huitième
cas de coronavirus confirmés en france
les pouces d'un patients hospitalisés à
annecy et premier français décédé cette
nuit à paris cet enseignant de 60 ans de
l'oise faisait partie des trois nouveaux
cas détectés en france à les chefs de
partis et présidents de groupes
parlementaires sont reçus demain à
matignon pour faire un point sur la
situation
en tous les cas le match lyon juventus
débutera bien dans quelques minutes
avec dans les tribunes des supporters
italiens c'est ce qu'a confirmé olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé
[Musique]
les négociations sur le budget européen
au point mort le sommet des chefs d'état
et de gouvernement en fin de semaine
dernière a échoué
elle est dans cette vont pourtant devoir
s'entendre pour compenser le départ du
royaume uni de l'union
mais pour l'instant personne n'est
d'accord ce blocage menace-t-il la pac
la politique agricole commune
c'est ce que nous verrons tout à l'heure
dans l'édito échos de jacques sapir
toujours pas d'avancée sur la réforme
des retraites le porte la porte parole
du gouvernement si bête ndiaye et
insiste pour que le débat parlementaire
ait lieu alors que plane le passage en
force avec le 49-3 à la contestation
populaire se poursuit notamment pour les
avocats il était cet après midi devant
l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
aux etats unis trois cadres du parti
démocrate réclame à l'anis
l'administration trump des sanctions
contre moscou en cause une note du
renseignement il est fait par de
soi-disant interférences russe dans la
campagne présidentielle américaine de
2000 20 mai la présentation de cette
note serait je cite trompeuses
de l'aveu même de responsables à la
sécurité nationale
[Musique]
le programme nucléaire iranien au coeur
des discussions en europe chine et
russie poursuivre les discussions à
vienne avec téhéran
si tous les participants ont réaffirmé
l'importance de préserver l'accord est
les tentatives de conciliation se
poursuivent pour la première fois depuis
le lancement d'une procédure contre
l'iran accusé de violer l'accord 2015 en
inde le premier ministre appelle au
calme dans la capitale new delhi est des
affrontements communautaires entre
hindous et musulmans ont fait 27 morts
et plus de 200 blessés ces violences
font suite à l'adoption d'une loi en
décembre
elle facilite l'attribution de la
citoyenneté aux réfugiés
à l'exception des musulmans
[Musique]
et on débute avec le coronavirus et un
dix huitième cas confirmés en france il
s'agit de l'épousé d'un patients
hospitalisés à annecy
mais l annonce a été faite tout à
l'heure par le ministre de la santé
olivier vers en elle cette nuit un homme
de 60 ans est décédé à paris il faisait
partie des trois nouveaux cas confirmés
sur le territoire français il ne s'était
pas rendue dans une zone d'exposition à
risque le ministre de la santé olivier
vers en a fait le point il ya quelques
minutes on les écoute il y à un 18e
patient qui a été diagnostiqué positif
pour le coronavirus il s'agit de
l'épousé du patient
actuellement hospitalisés à annecy et la
détection systématique du virus a permis
d'identifier que cette épouse du
patients hospitalisés à annecy était
positive pour le cours aux navires us
son état de santé n'est pas inquiétant
mais elle est évidemment hospitalisés et
isolé au même titre que les autres
malades
il n'y a pas eu d'autres diagnostics
positifs aujourd'hui pour le coronavirus
à laquelle à l'heure à laquelle je vous
parle la france continue dans sa
stratégie visant à freiner la diffusion
du virus
face aux risques épidémiques je le redis
ce soir il n'y a pas d'épidémie en
france nous faisons toujours face à des
cas des patients isolés que l'on s'est
expliquée par un voyage ou par un
contact avec une personne qui a été
elle-même contaminés à l'homme décédé la
nuit dernière à paris avait donc 60 ans
il était enseignant dans un collège de
l'oise à les hôpitaux se prépare face à
une éventuelle épidémie tandis qu'à nice
la ville a décidé d'annuler le carnaval
françois atys kevin ch
il avait 60 ans et était hospitalisé à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris
l'homme avait été testé en urgence mardi
dans un état gravissime
originaire de l'oise il avait été
d'abord admis à l'hôpital de creil qui a
décidé de déclencher le plan blanc
conséquence toutes les opérations non
urgentes qui étaient prévus sont
annulées et tout le personnel
hospitalier est en alerte mobilisables
très rapidement survenait à découvrir de
nouveaux cas enseignant dans un collège
à crépy en valois
il ne s'était pas rendue dans une zone
d'exposition à risque mais la préfecture
écarte toute contagion pour ses élèves
et ses collègues dès lors qu'il a été
prise en charge et bien n'a plus été en
contact à partir du 10 février avec des
élèves ou avec des parents d'élèves des
collègues enseignants
donc ce risque est écarté et puis nous
sommes le 26 février le de ce délai de
14 jours personne ne s'étant signalé
comme ayant des symptômes qui pourraient
être assimilées à une contagion par le
courant l'a virus et bien il ya tout
lieu de penser qu' il n'y a plus de
personnes contaminées
ce mercredi midi à l'issue du conseil
des ministres la porte parole du
gouvernement si bête ndiaye l'assurent
il n'y a toujours pas d'épidémie en
france et tout est mis en oeuvre pour y
faire face comme ici à l'institut
méditerranéen fiction de marseille
chercheurs médecins et laborantins sont
sur le pied de guerre pour réagir face à
une éventuelle pandémie de coronavirus
ans s'il s'avérait qu'un patient soit
porteur du corona chinois ou en cas de
patients qui présentent une forme sévère
d'infection qui justifie son
hospitalisation
les gars il est transféré immédiatement
au troisième étage de l'irfu dans le
service de maladies infectieuses où il
sera admis par l'intermédiaire d'un
un ascenseur dédié donc il ne croisera
pas ce patient aucun soignant ni aucun
autre patient et il sera donc installée
dans une chambre dépression est temps
que cette chambre est bien dû seront
admises télésoins éventuellement
l'administration de chloroquine ci
s'avère que c'est un virus pour un
navire chinois ou d'autres traitements
il se passera dans cette chambre jusqu'à
ce qu'ils soient jugés non contagieux à
nice situe à moins de 50 kilomètres de
la frontière italienne
la ville a décidé d'annuler les derniers
jours du carnaval à titre préventif
il devait se dérouler jusqu'à samedi
ce jeudi matin le premier ministre
edouard philippe recevra les chefs de
partis représentés au parlement
les présidents de groupes parlementaires
et les présidents d'assemblée afin de
faire un point sur la situation liée à
l'épidémie
et pour parler du coronavirus nous
retrouvons barbara qu elle est
infirmière à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris et membre du collectif inter
urgence à barbara coup et bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors en tant que professionnels de
santé quel est votre regard sur
l'évolution de l'épidémie
alors là c'est très cos
après nous avons quand même l'habitude
dé
les épidémies hivernales avec
les précautions d'usagé que chaque
soignant dans chaque service d'urgence
doit mettre en oeuvre pour se protéger
et protéger les autres patients qui sont
dans un service d'urgence après
effectivement sur ce virus spécifique en
france on a quand même aujourd'hui une
sorte de un manque de fluidité des
informations
les équipes sont dit j lente et sont
souvent en attente et réclame le
transfert des informations parce que
tout ce qui décide au niveau ministériel
n'est pas forcément encore à ce jour
arriver jusqu'aux au personnel de
terrain
alors on le sait les personnes les
personnels hospitaliers sont en grève
depuis des mois pour obtenir plus de
moyens
dans ce contexte les hôpitaux français
sont-ils prêts finalement à faire face à
une épidémie ben l'exemple typique de ce
qui s'est passé à creil nos collègues à
creil sont en grève depuis elles ont
passé leur un nom d'anniversaire avec
des grandes difficultés en terme de
personnel c'est vraiment la pratique de
toute une équipe qui a fait qu'elles ont
décidé de tester probablement ce patient
puisque à priori on n'avait pas de
facteur et ça rentre pas non plus dans
les prérogatives du ministère puisqu'il
n'y avait pas de on identifie pas encore
comment il aurait pu être contaminées au
coronavirus sauf que on voit que les
équipes sont toujours tous attentive à
ce qui va se passer et que elles sont
aujourd'hui en difficulté mais malgré
tout à fond leur travail le manque de
personnel c'est une réalité si
l'épidémie devait arriver aussi en
france comme on a pu le constater dans
le nord de l'italie
de la même manière des lits il veut on
nous annonce qui sont libérés mais nous
au quotidien on sait qu'on n'a pas de
place alors un homme est décédé à la
pitié salpêtrière on lisait quelles sont
les consignes vous en parler un peu tout
à l'heure mais plus précisément les
consignes appliquées très concrètement
dans les hôpitaux
comment est ce que vous vous protégez
les consignes on a fait un bilan au
niveau national
aujourd'hui elles sont vraiment très
disparate entre les les services qui
sont les hôpitaux centres pour certaines
régions aujourd'hui sont au nombre de
138 ils ont été augmentés
on imagine bien que c'est pas l'ensemble
des hôpitaux qui sont mobilisés donc les
consignes sont différentes pour tout le
monde aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est ça
reste surtout le bon sens des soignants
on n'a pas plus d'informations
donc c'est on se protège avec les
masques ffp2 pour pouvoir
on ne peut pas savoir ce temps que le
diagnostic n'a pas été validé au niveau
des laboratoires si la personne est
infectée ou non donc à ce jour il va
falloir anticiper et se protéger au delà
de ce qui sera réel dans les faits alors
dans quel état d'esprit aujourd'hui
dans quel état d'esprit aujourd'hui vous
êtes ainsi que que vos confrères les
personnels hospitaliers avec qui vous
travaillez est ce qu il ya de
l'inquiétude
l'inquiétude non une lassitude puisque
finalement depuis ces mois de grève dans
les services d'urgence où on n'a cessé
de rabâcher que si tout se passait des
problèmes sanitaires de grande envergure
en france les urgences le personnel qui
travaille aux urgences sera présent
flora ce qu'il a à faire c'est son
quotidien
simplement à un moment la réalité elle
sera à cet odieux tout le monde sait qu
on risque d'être en manque de personnel
est en manque de place et pour coup et
d'autant plus si le personnel tombe lui
aussi malade
donc c'est quand même un cercle vicieux
auquel on se demande quelle sera la
réponse
de notre nouveau ministre merci beaucoup
barbara coûts et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
infirmier à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris et membre du collectif interurbain
ans le coronavirus on continue d'en
parler avec le professeur yves buisson
membre de l'académie nationale de
médecine dilution bonsoir soir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors on va s'intéresser avec vous à
l'évolution du coronavirus on le disait
un premier français décédés il avait
locaux vides 19 mai il est mort d'une
embolie pulmonaire massive
cette embolie pulmonaire est ce que
c'est une conséquence directe de ce
coronavirus oui bien entendu c'est une
forme grave de l'infection avait
coronavirus il faut rappeler que la
majorité des infections dues à ce
coronavirus sont soit bénigne soit peu
grave
pas plus qu'une grippe normale mais il y
a effectivement surtout chez les
personnes qui sont soient âgées soient
porteuses d'une maladie chronique
il ya des formes très sévère et mais
mortel et l'atteinte pulmonaire qu'on
appelle le syndrome de détresse
respiratoire aiguë qui entraîne souvent
une défaillance multiviscérale c'est à
dire que le reins le foie
ne cessent de fonctionner et bien c'est
une conséquence malheureusement de ses
formes graves et qui mène aux déchets
donc finalement le profil type des
patients à risque au fond ce sont des
personnes plutôt âgées c'est bien cela
vous ne vite ou malades
oui on retrouve d'ailleurs les mêmes
personnes à risque pour les formes
graves de la grippe des personnes qui
sont censées d'ailleurs être vaccinés à
qui on recommande chaque année le vaccin
contre la grippe qui malheureusement ne
sont pas toutes vacciner pour que cette
année on est déjà je parle de la grippe
là à 55 décès en france et sur toutes
les formes graves de grippe qui sont
répertoriés 70 % n'avaient pas été
vaccinés rio donc pour revenir à
l'infection coronavirus on retrouve
effectivement les mêmes facteurs de
risque c'est-à-dire les pertes plus on
est âgé et moins se défend efficacement
le système immunitaire suse et la
défense de l'organisme contre
l'infection est moins efficace
et puis il y a les maladies associées
les traitement au long cours
1 les traitements notamment lé
traitement immuno suppresseurs qui
peuvent favoriser des formes graves
donc les patients cancéreux les patients
qui sont atteintes de pathologies
complexes chroniques seront bien entendu
beaucoup plus à risque d'être victime
d'une forme grave
quels sont les inconnus aujourd'hui qui
demeure encore et qui demandaient des
réponses rapides
alors bien sûr il ya beaucoup
d'inconnues il ya beaucoup d'inconnues
parce que ce que nous savons sur le
coronavirus on le tire un petit peu de
ce que l'on sait du
de l'ue coronavirus qui était
responsable du sahara ou du strass et
celui qui est responsable également de
du maire c'est à dire la fiction
coronavirus du moyen-orient on n'est
donc pas complètement ignorants mais ce
coronavirus se comporte un petit peu
différemment des autres notamment dans
ses formes cliniques les unes des
inconnus c est ce que les patients qui
sont en phase d'incubation c'est à dire
qu'ils sont infectés mais qui n'ont pas
encore commencé les symptômes et on sait
que cette phase d'incubation peut durer
au moins une semaine
est ce que ces patients sont contagieux
ou ne le sont pas il ya des éléments qui
laissent penser que peut-être il
pourrait être transmetteur avant d'avoir
développé des symptômes est ce que les
patients qui font des formes très mineur
asymptomatiques c'est à dire des
patients non repérable des patients qui
ne vont pas consultés est ce que ces
patients lorsqu'ils sont infectés et dès
qu'ils ont des formes donc
asymptomatiques est ce qu'ils sont de
possibles transmetteur on le soupçonne
mais on n'en est pas sûr
voyez ce sont des choses que l'on saura
progressivement au fur et à mesure que
l'épidémie s'étende en se développant
les recherches au fur et à mesures vont
permettre de tirer un certain nombre de
connaissances que dont on dispose pas
encore parce que c'est c'est encore très
récent cette histoire de coronavirus
armande quand même au mois de décembre
en tous les cas il y a des consignes
pour pour s'en prémunir le ministre de
la santé ou du vivant
conseille de se laver les mains une fois
par heure il ya une production de 15
millions de masques en plus une bonne
chose c'est nécessaire aujourd'hui
alors bon ce sont les méthodes efficaces
sont les muscles d'appel des méthodes
barrières bien entendu alors tout le
monde parle du masque alors il faut être
très clair sur le masque la plupart des
masques que l'on voit dans les
reportages sont des masques de type
chirurgical
ils n'ont aucune efficacité démontrée
pour se protéger par contre ils sont
efficaces
lorsqu'on les places sur les voies
respiratoires des patients suspects ou
des patients atteints dans des patients
potentiellement contagieux parce que ces
masques chirurgicaux permettent
d'arrêter les flux de virus et donc
d'empêcher qu'il contamine maintenant si
on veut se protéger si on est au contact
d'un malade il faut porter un masque
dont a parlé madame l'infirmière
beaucoup et qui sont les masques de type
ffp2 qui sont des masques qui enveloppe
très très étroitement le massif facial
et cure une pièce filtrantes
il faut savoir aussi que les masques on
peut pas les garder toute la journée
au bout de deux à trois heures les
masques il faut les changer parce qu'ils
sont d'abord le sol le filtre est bouché
et puis à l'humidité de la respiration
il faut donc qu'il n'exerce ils sont
plus efficaces
quant au lavage des mains avec
l'utilisation des solutions
hydro-alcooliques bien entendu il faut
lui recommander il faut pas non plus
passer son temps se laver les mains
parce que c'est vous dire c'est mais
chaque fois qu'on a eu un contact avec
des personnes que l'on ne connaît pas et
si on a pris le métro
1 vous les transports en commun on a
tenu la barre de sécurité
on se laver se laver merci beaucoup pour
tout ces conseils professeur yves
buisson je rappelle que vous êtes membre
de l'académie nationale de médecine
les résultats viennent de tomber rt
france ne sera pas mise en demeure une
seconde fois par le csa ce matin à les
représentants de notre chaîne ont été
reçus en audience est entendu par le
conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel est cette procédure de
sanction s'est ouverte suite à la
diffusion d'un sujet en avril 2019 dans
ce sujet il est fait état des
déclarations d'un général russe à propos
de la syrie pour rappel le rapporteur
indépendant auprès du csa avait
préconisé de ne pas sanctionner un autre
média et pour en parler maître david
koubbi l'un des avocats de arte france
est avec nous sur ce plateau david
couilles bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france pouvez
vous nous rappeler dans un premier temps
pourquoi rt france et est auditionné par
le csa aujourd'hui alors très
précisément pour les raisons que vous
venez d'évoquer c'est à dire que votre
rédaction des journalistes de votre
chaînes ont relayé la parole d'un
officiel
un russe sur le conflit en syrie est le
sujet qui semble avoir inquiété le csa
était très précisément le fait qu'il ait
été cité
or pour ce que j'ai pu revoir
les journalistes de votre rédaction ont
parfaitement bien fait leur travail dès
lors que la source était rappelé que le
conditionnel étaient employés et nous
sommes dans une configuration où
aujourd'hui le csa a décidé fort
heureusement il convient non seulement
de s'en féliciter mais de l'en féliciter
de ne pas prononcer de sanction à votre
endroit qu'est ce qui se jouait pour rt
francise été où les enjeux les enjeux
étaient cruciaux les enjeux étaient de
première importance puisque les
sanctions pouvant être prononcée pouvait
pouvait aller très clairement jusqu'à la
rupture de la convention qui lie la
chaîne arte france avec le csa c'est à
dire au delà
l'arrêt de la diffusion comment est-ce
que le csa a finalement a motivé sa
décision de ne pas attribuer de
sanctions rt france il l'a motivé d'une
manière que j'estime des plus saines
dès lors qu'il a rappelé que la source
de l'information qui a été diffusé sur
l'antenne de rtl france était rappelé
que les précautions d'usagé
quand je dis d'usagé c'est-à-dire d'usa
journalistique avait été respecté par
l'emploi notamment du conditionnel je ne
tiens pas à être trop technique dans la
réponse que je vous fais mais pour le
dire ainsi que les usages en alice tic
avaient été respectées que révèle cette
décision au fond du csa c'est un bon
signe la procédure en elle même je ne
veux pas être polémique mais la
procédure en elle-même ne révèle pas
n'est pas n'est pas un très bon signal
la procédure en elle même était un peu
étonnante parce que vous savez j'ai eu
l'occasion de plaider ce matin pour le
compte de votre chaîne
c'était le procès du selon puisque vos
journalistes disaient selon un général
russe
voici ce qui a été dit toutes les
chaînes dit selon washington selon
johnson selon poutine selon trump selon
macron donc on ne peut pas faire le
procès du selon vous comprenez ça n'est
pas audible puisque vous citez la
personnalité qui qui en parlent les les
enjeux
voilà quel est ce qu'ils étaient pour
conclure de façon plus globale cette
décision elle est un bon signal pour
vous pour la liberté la pluralité de la
presse à nouveau la procédure non quant
à la décision
c'est un très bon signal parce que le
csa a fait oeuvre et a fait montre
d'indépendance aujourd'hui dans un
contexte qui frappe votre chaîne qu'il
convient de rappeler rt france et est
sujet à des critiques qui ne sont pas
des critiques justifiées qui sont pour
moi des critiques calomnieuse il est il
a été dit que vous n'étiez pas des
journalistes ça nous fera sans doute
réagir au sourire ça vous fait sourire
il a été dit que vous étiez à la solde
d'une puissance étrangère et nous nous
avons rappelé tout au contraire que vous
étiez un groupe de presse français que
vous employez des journalistes français
munis de cartes de presse française et
au delà vous savez de la décision qui
touche r t aujourd'hui je crois qu'il ya
un sujet qui tient à la liberté de la
presse à la pluralité de la presse et
samedi en france vous dit pardon c'est
un ranger aujourd'hui en france ce
manque de liberté de pluralité en tout
cas de la presse c'est quelque chose que
vous observez quand un groupe de presse
français comme le vôtre est poursuivi
devant le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel pour avoir citer sa source
c'est à dire avoir fait son travail
avoir respecté la charte de munich avoir
respecté la déontologie du journaliste
quand ce dossier est arrivé sur mon
bureau vous savez je suis docteur en
droit de la presse donc je suis habitué
aux sujets qui touchent à la presse en
général et aux droits de la presse en
particulier
j'ai lu la notification de griefs et jeu
j'ai du mal à comprendre je n'avais pas
très bien suivi l'évolution de l'opinion
en tout cas de l'opinion politique pas
de l'opinion publique de l'opinion
politique attachée à arte et je ne
comprenais pas très bien quels étaient
ses griefs à nouveau vous avez cités sur
ce plateau ou un autre de votre chaîne a
été cité un général russe
il n'y a pas de faits délictueux ici il
n'y a rien qui violent la loi les
règlements la déontologie des
journalistes et la décision qui a été
rendue aujourd'hui par le csa est une
décision qui me semble t'il fait oeuvre
d'indépendance dans un contexte
politique ou du plus haut niveau de
l'état
je dis bien du plus haut niveau de
l'état jusqu'à des sénateurs des députés
des directeurs de campagne
il y avait comme ça un petit bruit de
fond une espèce de mode qui tendait à
dire que rtl arte france n'étais pas mû
par des journalistes n'étaient pas un
organe de presse français aujourd'hui le
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel vient
clairement de dire le contraire et il a
eu raison de le faire puisque vous êtes
lié au csa par une convention que vous
avez parfaitement bien respecté
puisqu'il n'y a pas de sanction
prononcée contre heart et pouvant aller
je le rappelle jusqu'à l'interdiction
donc en tant qu'avocat je me réjouis de
cette victoire et je me réjouis en tant
que citoyen français que le droit de la
presse soit respectueux des libertés
d'opinion tels que nous les aimons dans
ce pays le csa comment at il été saisi
il s'est auto saisie sur cette affaire
comment ça se passe voilà vous savez
c'est toujours un peu compliqué de le
dire mais il y a eu un tweet d'une
ministre
qui était sous forme de blague en lien
avec ce reportage qui était le reportage
vu comme étant litigieux et il y a eu
des dénonciations que nous retrouvons au
dossier d'opposants russes qui semble
confondre ce qui se passe en russie et
ce qui se passe sur vos plateaux alors
que vos plateaux sont mus par des
journalistes français
ce dont je peux témoigner si besoin en
était encore merci beaucoup david koubbi
d'avoir apporté votre éclairage sur
notre bateau je rappelle que vous êtes
l'un des avocats de rt france merci de
votre invitation et dans quelques
instants ce sera les dites aux échos de
jacques sapir ce soir il s'intéresse au
budget de l'union européenne avec cette
question est la pac la politique
agricole commune était l'otage du bric
site puis direction les états-unis ou
trois démocrates veulent sanctionner
moscou selon une note du renseignement
la russie tenterait d'influencer la
présidentielle
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
le numérique ça et mais aujourd'hui 4 %
des gaz à effet de serre dans le monde
tous les citoyens qui utilisent par
exemple des ordinateurs polluent la
planète
à chaque fois qu'on a une requête
internet on envoie un email
qu'on l'ait qu'une photo sur instagram
ça a un impact carbone un email envoyé
avec une pièce jointe
c'est l'équivalent d'une ampoule allumée
pendant une heure comme celle ci peu de
gens ont conscience que le numérique
pollue pire encore ils pensent que le
numérique est un outil qui permettrait
de réduire la consommation d'énergie le
numérique est en quelque sorte un
pharmaco pharma concept un mot grec
ancien qui veut dire à la être à la fois
remède est poison c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut qu'il faut utiliser avec
avec sagesse avec mesure qu'est ce qui
fera le plus de bien à la planète
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même je
m'appelle jean biart j'ai 18 ans je
crois en effet d'entraînement
nous on va leur enseigner leur show
c'est l'école d'arts martiaux du temple
de shaolin
et le ça fait trois fois que je te le
dis tu ne comprends pas où tu vas
t'entraîner tout seul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore une fois c'est pas bon comme si
c'était la première fois en jouant à
saute tourne encore les filles le font
mieux croit en toi et tu réussiras
[Musique]
on
direct ce navire est très simple mais
c'est pas du tout le cas
en réalité le vrai maître c'est l'ours
blanc est en 2d le brise glace
nous avons entrepris une mission unique
peut être la première de ce type dans
l'histoire de la marine russe
donald trump est à l'affût de 5
milliards enfin en tout cas preuve pour
une première tranche de travaux dont la
barrière n'est pas totalement construite
la totalité de la frontière c'est plus
de 3000 km le président des états unis
reprend le discours qu'il avait comme
candidat le présentant les migrants
comme des vecteurs de délinquance de
criminalité le trafic de drogue
il est certain que la majorité des
migrants et mexicains ou centres
américains qui sont aux etats-unis ne
sommes pas là pour faire du trafic de
drogue mais pour travailler
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france il est 20h30
heure française tout de suite l'édito de
jacques sapir et ce soir il est question
de la politique agricole commune la pac
peut-elle être l'otage du bric site
c'est ce qui angoisse le monde paysan
alors que le salon de l'agriculture bat
son plein après l'échec des négociations
sur le budget européen les 27 restent
divisés sur la façon de compenser le
départ du royaume uni alors qui va payer
pour les britanniques après le break
site
pour l'instant personne n'est vraiment
d'accord l'agriculture risque-t-elle de
faire les frais de ce blocage
on voit cela tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bienvenue
jacques bienvenu merci beaucoup olivier
alors la pac politique agricole commune
peut-elle être l'otage du bric si tu
sais ce qui angoisse le monde paysan
alors effectivement c'est que c'est sous
cette forme que l'on a posé le problème
en particulier à la suite du sommet
européen du 21 février
il faut savoir que évidemment la pac est
très importante pour la france
le président emmanuel macron à
d'ailleurs dit qu'il ne voulait pas que
le bric site se fasse au détriment de la
pac
maintenant il faut comprendre aussi que
au delà du problème posé par la pac est
il y a le problème plus généralement du
budget européen du conflit qui lie à
autour de ce budget européen et que dont
justement c'est ce conflit dans cet
affrontement qui lie à entre certains
pays
eh bien la france est plutôt en bonne
position puisque la france se trouve
être une donatrice net à l'union
européenne
alors avant d'aller plus loin jacques
que je vous propose de voir ce qu'en
pensent les français que nous avons
rencontré devant le salon de
l'agriculture regardez écoutez je pense
que les agriculteurs français
sont bien aidés par alors je vois si
c'est la pac mais par l'europe
si j'ai bien compris ce que disent les
économistes la france dans en
bénéficient mais l'angleterre était
largement bénéficiaire et puis qui se
sentiraient club réussit il ya un trou
et les agriculteurs vont souffrir on est
un pays de tradition agricole plus que
certains oui que nos voisins donc que
c'est de l'importance pour nous je
trouve que c'est pas étonnant les
agriculteurs ils ont envie de
pouvoir avoir un salaire en travaillant
et pas en ayant des aides
donc c'est sûr ça permet de maintenir
une activité mais la pérenniser c'est
plus compliqué avec des êtres que de
travailler et d'avoir un salaire qui est
le fruit de son travail
on a des agriculteurs qui sont
des amis et qui travaille énormément et
ils ont pas de fruits en fait un pas
deux salaires d'autres se suicident
puisque on en entend parler dans les
médias
je sais que déjà ils ont pas d comme
tout artisan une retraite bien bien
belle
monsieur macro lemaitre à 1000 euros
mais pas pour tout le monde je crois
alors peut-être que oui le petit coup de
pouce ça serait pas mal
il y à des agriculteurs qui sont
effectivement en danger sont des dix
exploitations les très grosses
exploitations n'ont pas trop de
problèmes parce qu'ils exportent pense
que à 27
on doit pouvoir encore bien se
débrouiller même sens les anglais s'ils
veulent pas contribuer à la maison
commune peut pas les forcer à l'orge à
quel est votre réaction à ce que nous
venons d'entendre
alors on voit bien que les français
qu'on a interrogés et ils réagissent
d'abord sur le problème de la pac et
c'est tout à fait normal
et puis après ils posent effectivement
la question de savoir est ce que le
départ du royaume uni de l'union
européenne ne va-t-il pas justement
déséquilibré de manière irrémédiable le
budget exact où d'abord qu'est ce que
représente la pac pour la france la pac
évidemment c'est un gros morceau si vous
voulez c'est extrêmement important pour
les agriculteurs français
la pac ça représente grosso modo 60 % de
l'ensemble des subventions que nous
recevons et on voit ici d'ailleurs que
et bien la pac est très concentré sur un
certain nombre de pays et en particulier
cinq pays dont la france garde et 9
milliards d'euros reçue du fait de la
pac mais il ya d'autres pays comme
l'allemagne l'espagne l'italie voire la
pologne
donc on voit bien la pac c'est très
important c'est très important pour les
agriculteurs même si on peut regretter
que les subventions de la pac ne soit
peut-être pas également répartie et puis
c'est très concentré sur un certain
nombre de pays mais alors en quoi le
départ du royaume uni le président
pose-t-il un problème
et bien si vous voulez pour comprendre
cela il faut d'abord avoir en tête
l'ordre de grandeur du budget le budget
européen ses 153 milliards à peu près
d'euros sur ses 153 milliards évidemment
il y à des dépenses d'administration
direct environ 20 milliards indirects
probablement
une douzaine de milliards bref et quand
on regarde du côté des recettes et bien
on voit que et bien encore une fois il
ya cinq pays là avec la grande bretagne
qui font une très grosse partie des
recettes les 22 autres pays bas taux les
23 autres pays puisque la grande
bretagne compte et ne représente en fait
qu'une part mineure des recettes et puis
il ya les autres ressources de l'union
européenne ne voit que c'est vraiment
pas grand chose alors évidemment ces
cinq pays
eh bien il pèse lourd et en particulier
le cas de la grande-bretagne qui va
payer net 7 milliards d'euros
pourtant sept milliards à trouver ce
n'est pas impossible non effectivement
on peut penser que ce n'est pas
impossible mais il faut remettre ça dans
la perspective de ce que l'on appelle la
programmation budgétaire qui étaient
décidées par l'union européenne qui
s'étend de 2020 à 2025 alors ce budget
programmé sur sept ans il se monte à
plus de 1000 milliards d'euros et la
contribution britannique se voit là elle
se montrait à 75 milliards d'euros
c'est à dire à peu près à 7% ce qui est
beaucoup plus que par rapport au budget
de 2020 alors après il y a évidemment
toujours le problème
cette soul et cette logique de
contribution eh bien elle repose aussi
sur le fait que certains pays sont des
donateurs net d'autres ne le sont pas et
on voit évidemment que là il va y avoir
un problème parce que évidemment si les
donateurs net se retire il reste plus
grand chose alors jacques ce que vous
nous dites et que certains pays
structurellement paye plus qu'ils ne
reçoivent de l'union européenne est tout
à fait et ça encore si on prend si vous
voulez un les cinq plus gros
contributeur au budget européen
eh bien on s'aperçoit que quatre d'entre
eux royaume uni italie france allemagne
ont un écart entre ce qu'ils versent ici
et ce qu'ils reçoivent ici globalement
cet écart se monte à 38 milliards
et là ça commence à représenter ça
représente un peu plus de 20 points
sans du des dépenses du budget européen
oui c'est quelque chose effectivement
d'important et avec le départ de la
grande bretagne
eh bien on a un déséquilibre dans ce
solde des donateurs alors est ce que
cela veut dire que pour vous cette crise
est insoluble
écoutez il n'y a pas de crise qui soit
en théorie insoluble bien entendu le
problème qui va se poser c'est est ce
que l'on a réellement la volonté de
résoudre cette crise est là on va
retomber sur le problème il y à des pays
qui ne veulent faire des économies ce
qu'on appelle les pays frugaux 1
autriche allemagne pays bas danemark et
suède et puis il ya des pays qui sont
d'accord pour dépenser plus
comme la france et l'italie est donc le
conflit va venir de là il va venir que
du fait qu'il ya des pays qui disent mme
banon veut pas donner plus et d'autres
pays qui disent pas on pourrait
peut-être mettre un petit peu la main à
la poche et on voit bien que c'est sur
ce point que vont se concentrer les
affrontements mais alors jacques que
devient l'union européenne alors c'est
effectivement un point important parce
que si on revient au problème de la pac
on voit très bien que la france pourrait
se décider à renationaliser la pâte
si elle a renationalisé la pac elle
utilise de ce point de vue là l'argent
qu'elle donne en plus à l'union
européenne
sauf que si on arrive dans ce type de
logique bien quelle est la raison
d'existence de l'union européenne on
voit bien que c'est en réalité le
problème existentiel qui a été posée par
le brr eti par le départ du royaume uni
donc à ce moment là si on va toujours
dans cette logique et bien sans la
france l'union européenne ne fait plus
grand sens
au mieux elle se réduira à une sorte de
zone marque ou disons une zone
d'influencé de l'allemagne ce qui
d'ailleurs ne va pas faire plaisir à
d'autres pays en particulier l'italie la
pologne voire la hongrie donc il y à un
véritable problème et ce problème est
d'autant plus important que aujourd'hui
la grande bretagne est parti
merci beaucoup jacques pour toutes ces
explications comme toujours très
instructive à très bientôt sur rt france
merci beaucoup
lé débat sur la réforme des retraites
s'enlise lors de son point presse
hebdomadaire cib et n'diaye a fustigé
l'obstruction faite par l'opposition à
la porte parole du gouvernement estime
que le débat parlementaire doit avoir
lieu je ne désespère pas que les uns et
les autres puissent revenir à la raison
et décidé faire le choix d'offrir un
spectacle de meilleure qualité si j'ose
dire à nos concitoyens car au fond à
quoi sert un débat parlementaire
un débat parlementaire permet d'enrichir
un texte qui est proposée par le
gouvernement enrichir évidemment par des
amendements de sa propre majorité mais
aussi et ça a été le cas sur la plupart
des textes de lois qui ont été examinés
depuis cette mandature de 2,2 comment
dire d'amendements qui viennent de nos
oppositions et donc l'idée est bien de
faire en sorte que le texte initial
présenté par le gouvernement soit un
texte qui soit enrichi et qui reflète le
débat parlementaire y les avocats
maintiennent la pression sur le
gouvernement concernant la réforme des
retraites ils ont manifesté devant
l'assemblée nationale pour dénoncer la
modification de leur régime de retraite
et l'absence d' écoute du ministère de
la justice ait les robes noires pointe
le doublement de leurs cotisations et
craignent de voir un grand nombre de
cabinets mettre la clé sous la porte
je vous propose en écouter quelqu'un on
proteste contre le projet de loi de
réforme des retraites parce que ce
projet va faire que la moitié des
cabinets vont fermer en seine saint
denis c'est plus de la moitié des
cabinets qui vont fermer parce que le
gouvernement va doubler nos cotisations
etc cette réforme des retraites
le doublement de nos cotisations
implique que tous les avocats qui
s'occupe notamment des personnes les
plus faibles des plus démunis et qui ont
donc des revenus les plus faibles aussi
vont devoir fermer leurs cabinets et les
justiciables encore une fois les plus
les plus fragiles qui vont se trouver
pénaliser outre les avocats c'est pas
simplement une manifestation
corporatiste des avocats c'est aussi
pour une certaine idée de la justice du
service public de la justice auxquelles
les avocats concours
que nous manifestent pas c'est une
profession dont maintenant la france
s'aperçoit parce que jusqu'à présent
vivait sur l'idée un peu surfaite d'une
profession nantis et la profession
d'avocat est la profession la plus
pauvre du droit elle a la majorité des
avocats perçoivent un revenu moyen de
40000 euros par an sur des exercices
totalement libéraux donc à leur charge
et ne n'a pas du tout eu les clés les
capacités financières de résister à un
doublement des charges et à une
réduction de l'âge de la retraite future
moscou toujours dans le viseur des états
unis de hauts responsables démocrates
ont demandé à ce que la mise
l'administration trump impose de
nouvelles sanctions contre la russie en
cause la tentative présumée d'ingérence
russe annoncé par le renseignement
américain aux membres du congrès
explications d'antoine claireaux notre
correspondre à moscou trois sénateurs
démocrates ont écrit au secrétaire
d'état mac pompéo et au secrétaire au
trésor stephen low chine pour exiger que
l'administration trump à pose
immédiatement et avec force des
sanctions contre le gouvernement et les
citoyens russes soupçonnés d'implication
dans la supposée ingérence électorale
l'administration trump a la possibilité
d'imposer des sanctions pour l'ingérence
dans nos élections
elle n'a pas besoin de nouveaux outils
législatifs ou d'approbation
notre message est clair secrétaire
moo-jin imposer des sanctions
immédiatement faire quoi que ce soit 2 -
reviendrait à vous dédouaner de votre
responsabilité de protection et de
défense des états unis envers cette
grave menace contre notre sécurité
nationale et contre l'intégrité de notre
processus électoral et les trois élus
signataires ne sont pas les premiers
venus
chuck schaeffer est le leader de la
minorité démocrate au sénat tandis que
bob menendez et sherrod brown sont
respectivement en charge des comités
sénatoriaux des relations étrangères et
bancaire les qu'elle supervise la
politique de sanctions quant à la
réaction de moscou à l'envoi de cette
lettre elle n'a pas tardé l'ambassade de
russie aux etats-unis exprime sa
profonde préoccupation face à la
tournure des spéculations sur l'
ingérence présumée de la russie dans les
élections à mairie
n il est particulièrement frappant de
voir comment les forces politiques à
washington
exploite ce mythe pour en tirer un gain
politique faire des allégations non
liées à la russie totalement infondées
et fictive devient une bien mauvaise
tradition politique aux etats unis
lorsqu'il n'ya pas suffisamment
d'arguments lorsqu'il n'ya pas
suffisamment d'outils pour mener un
combat politique sur le plan domestique
ont fait appel à ce facteur russe c'est
une triste réalité à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés depuis de nombreuses
années
mais au fait que contient ce brief du
renseignement américain on y apprend via
les médias d'outre-atlantique que moscou
semble se livrer à des campagnes de
désinformation et de propagande pour
aider à la fois le favori pour
l'investiture démocrate bernie sanders
mais aussi le président sortant donald
trump qui entend bien se faire réélire
au mois de novembre
un récit qui repose entièrement sur des
sources anonymes non vérifiables et qui
est malheureusement amené à se répéter
selon le porte parole du kremlin il
s'agit là de nouveaux messages
paranoïaque qui malheureusement seront
de plus en plus nombreux à la proche des
élections
bien sûr cela n'a rien à voir avec la
vérité alors que la soi-disant ingérence
russe est de nouveau bondi aux états
unis à la proche de la présidentielle
moscou estime que cette pseudo menace de
l'extérieur est instrumentalisée à des
fins de politique intérieure
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis washington avec ben swan
journaliste d'investigation c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
lebens one bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors une
de présumer ingérence russe c'est devenu
une rengaine non effectivement c'est la
même rengaine
nous l'avons déjà vu en 2007 on en parle
est une ingérence russe et en 2020 c'est
la même chose mais nous apprenons
beaucoup plus de choses sur la façon
cela se déroule ce que l'on voit surtout
c'est que ces services du renseignement
ne sont pas vraiment du renseignement
alors en ce qui concerne justement les
conclusions du renseignement américain
qu'en retenir sont à la charge
finalement contre la russie voici les
conclusions générales de ces accusations
la communauté du renseignement a publié
une déclaration disant que la fédération
russe notamment vladimir poutine avait
exprimé une préférence et elle
souhaitait relire donna truax qui avait
également montré une préférence pour
bernie sanders
mais quelques jours ensuite on a
découvert que le document tel qu'il
existait ne correspondait pas à ce qui
avait été dit est la personne qui va
publier l'information avait interprété
les conclusions elle disait ce qu'elle
pensait étaient les objectifs des russes
mais en réalité lorsqu'on étudie ce
qu'on a trouvé
il s'agit simplement d'un intérêt des
russes qui pensait qu'il pourrait
travailler avec donald trump s'il était
réélu il n'était pas dit qu'ils les
essayer de s'ingérer donc l'accusation
d'ingérence et bien au delà d'une simple
affirmation que les dirigeants et
certains pays pensent être capables de
travailler avec les
un autre pays et pourtant on le voit
dans les débats et au sein des médias
il ya une explosion de rhétorique autour
de ce sujet on pense que les russes
essaient et était de la truck et bernie
sanders en même temps et pourtant ces
deux candidats sont totalement opposés
mais aujourd'hui c'est une insulte de
parler des deux russes dont vous comment
comprendre cette volonté du camp
démocrate de sanctionner moscou à ce
qu'il chercha à réveiller les fantômes
du passé
je pense effectivement qu'il réveille
les fantômes du passé et du présent
en effet c'est vraiment un fantôme
qu'ils ont créé de toutes pièces
c'est une terminologie autour de la
russie c'est une forme d'épouvantail
selon lequel la russie serait une grande
menace à l'époque de la guerre froide
c'était une menace nucléaire mais ce
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
donc lorsqu'on demande aujourd'hui aux
gens quelle est la menace représentée
par la russie pour les 2000 peuvent pas
expliquer ne savent pas ce que c'est il
ya beaucoup de menaces dans le monde
entier notamment par exemple d'autres
grandes puissances telles que la chine
également au niveau militaire ainsi qu
économique mais la russie n'est pas du
tout au même niveau donc la terminologie
utilisée qui est réapparu lors du débat
démocrate d'hier la première question du
débat ça pressait à bernie sanders et la
riposte de michael bloomberg était que
c'est les russes qu'ils voulaient que
bernie sanders remporte les élections
donc cette terminologie tourner et très
péjorative autour des russes mais pour
la plupart des américains lorsqu'on leur
demande de se qui fait si peur avec la
russie ne peuvent pas expliquer parce
qu'ils savent juste que c'est mal alors
vous en parliez bernie sanders favori
des primaires démocrates auraient les
faveurs de moscou selon les agences de
renseignement américaines
est-ce qu'il faut y croire
non je ne pense pas qu'ils sont dans son
camp les russes se sont peut-être
demander s'ils pouvaient travailler avec
bernie sanders en tant que président ils
ont dû penser qu'il le pouvait et ils
ont déjà dit qu'ils pensaient qu'il fait
également travailler avec de la trump
c'est là que la situation devient
étrange on pourrait s'imaginer que dans
notre pays on voudrait un dirigeant qui
peut coopérer avec les autres dirigeants
mondiaux
mais il y a beaucoup qui cela sionisme
dans ce pays est quelqu'un qui veut
travailler avec d'autres dirigeants est
considéré comme un patriote
donc c'est un genre d'ambiguïté assez
intéressante
l'establishment républicains comme
démocrates fait usage de cette
terminologie de ce discours afin de
discréditer certains candidats
le président trump a été discrédité
selon eux avec cette proximité avec des
dictateurs maintenant il essaye
d'utiliser la même rhétorique pour
bernie sanders en disant qu'il est
proche du dictateur
merci beaucoup bensman pour votre
éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste d'investigation troisième
jour de procès pour julian assange
devant la justice britannique le
fondateur de wikileaks s'est plaint ce
mercredi d'avoir des échanges assez
privé avec ses avocats
une sortie vite interrompue par la juge
qui a ordonné une courte pause londres
doit décider de donner suite ou non à la
demande américaine d'extradition du
lanceur d alerte australien il est
poursuivi pour espionnage et piratage
informatique et risque jusqu'à 175 ans
de prison on écoute l'une de ses
avocates
l'accusation a ouvert le dossier en
citant une déclaration du journal the
guardian en 2011 qui prenait ses
distances et condamné julian assange
pour avoir publié les câbles
diplomatiques
cela dit cette accusation ne vaut pas
car c'est le journaliste du guardian qui
a divulgué le mot de passe lui même je
pense donc qu'il est vraiment important
de prendre note enfin de tenir compte de
la chronologie qui a été présenté
aujourd'hui au tribunal
julian assange a effectivement pris des
mesures de sécurité importantes et
responsables pour essayer de protéger
ces documents et selon stéphanie gibeau
lanceuse d'alert certains risquent bien
pire que des menaces on écoute le procès
assange catalyse la problématique c'est
à dire qu'à partir du moment où on se
lève à partir de mon roman parle
à partir du moment où on dit la vérité
on doit être exécuté quelle que soit la
laërt quel que soit le sujet alors comme
wikileaks qui est une publication qui
n'a fait que donner des informations
d'intérêt général et qui sont
effectivement très dommageable pour nos
états étant donné ce qui nous était
cachée on comprend que le gouvernement
américain les gouvernements américain et
pu lui en vouloir beaucoup
maintenant il s'agit du combat pour la
vérité il s'agit du combat aussi des
droits de l'homme
est ce que ceux qui disent la vérité
doivent être plus condamnés que ceux qui
assassinent ceux qui mentent ceux qui
trompent ceux qui les vannes le fisc etc
etc
et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment la société civile qui doit
s'emparer de ces sujets puisqu'on a vu
que tous ceux qui étaient censés
soutenir notamment nos hommes politiques
notamment les associations notamment
mais il ya eu absolument personne donc
merci à tous ceux qui se mobilisent et
je pense que ce n'est que le début d'une
mobilisation à l'international après
quatre mois de blocage la vie politique
reprend son cours en tunisie à
l'assemblée des représentants du peuple
a entamé cet après-midi une séance
extraordinaire consacrée au vote de
confiance au nouveau gouvernement
tunisien
une équipe formée par elyès fakfak le
premier ministre fraîchement élu plus
grande force au parlement le parti
d'inspiration islamiste ennahda à six
ministres au sein de cette équipe
à l'ouverture de la séance plénière le
chef du gouvernement a évoqué les
priorités du pays si on les écoute au
matap denton
la tunisie ne peut progresser vers la
réussite qu'avec des sacrifices et pour
faire des réformes
il nous faut un gouvernement fort
capable de se sacrifier et il va se
sacrifier
il nous faut un parlement qui
travaillent main dans la main avec le
gouvernement il le soutient et le
contrôle pour moi ken si vous voulez que
nous rétablissions la confiance du
peuple
il faut changer la façon de travailler
organiser nos priorités et arrêté
d'éparpiller nos efforts il ya des
priorités urgentes qui ne peuvent pas
attendre et des sujets brûlants pour les
tunisiens
et si dieu le veut vous allez nous
accorder votre confiance
nous allons traiter ses priorités dès le
premier jour
justement neuf ans après le printemps
arabe les attentes sont nombreux chez
les tunisiens c'est ce que nous dit la
mine smoothie essayiste auteur de la
politique des idées tunisiens attendent
une amélioration de la situation sociale
parce que cette révolution s'est faite
de manière institutionnelle sur les
dents les institutions on a eu une
réelle démocratisation mais oh
mais au niveau économique c'est une
décadence qui n'en finit de qui n'en
finit de toucher les tunisiens c'est une
baisse du pouvoir d'achat c'est une
hausse des prix et c'est ce que attendre
principalement les tunisiens une
amélioration de la situation économique
et dans quelques instants direction
vienne où se déroule une réunion entre
européens chine et russie pour chercher
avec téhéran un terrain d'entente sur
son programme nucléaire
nous irons ensuite en inde où le premier
ministre mme odile appel au calme après
des violences communautaires à new delhi
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que la chine est la nouvelle
superpuissance du sport tout est
réalisable à la mesure de l'ambition
dévorante de la chine
je pense que dans les années à venir ça
va être un rival important pour être
pour dominer le sport mondial
l'ambition que ce que s'est donnée le
président jean ping s'est non seulement
d'avoir le plus grand nombre de
médailles mais d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de chinois qui pratiquent le
sport le football c'est sympathiquement
une des sports les plus connues dans le
monde et la chine ne veut en faire
partie et votre règne les meilleurs il
ya aussi un petit peu comme en russie
une volonté de nationaliser un peu de
sport indirectement en obligeant les
grands patrons des grandes entreprises
qui appartiennent toutes au parti
communiste à investir ans parlait des
plus grandes fortunes chinoises sont
tout propriétaire d'un club de foot show
l'intéressé de dettes d'abord deux
d'être reconnus d'être reconnu en tant
qu'expert est de faire en sorte que la
chine soit reconnu comme un grand pays
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent là l on soit vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
au cambodge tu fais si vous au cambodge
étaient instituteurs
vous avez ici un emploi qui vous
satisfait en somme
c'est grâce en fait l entraide dans
cette commune aux tic mes parents ont pu
à la fois trouver un travail
trouver aussi un appartement ou revivre
le besoin de réussir est l'un des buts
principaux du migrants chinois
il est clair que c'est une communauté à
travers laquelle ne voit pas et qu'il
est très difficile de pénétrer et où ne
sais pas ce qui s'y passe en politique
on commence à voir quelques visages
d'origine asiatique mais je trouve que
ça manque encore ça manque notamment
dans les médias à la télévision qui
sommes nous aujourd'hui on dans cette
société française et comment peut-on en
fait vivre en harmonie avec cette
diversité on dit tout simplement une
chose dit c'est nous français
[Musique]
des ogm c'est la cerise sur le gâteau de
la culture intensive et chimiques il le
nombre de techniques pour faire les ogm
a explosé pendant les 15 dernières
années les ogm si tu as un outil sait
tous qu'il a il ne pourra rien faire
contre la faim dans le monde jusqu'en
fait la faim dans le monde est une
question politique
alors ça c'est les ogm il ya également
le glyphosate alors le groupe 7 à usage
agricole
on pourrait s'en passer il ya des façons
de produire qui peut se passer de tout
thermicien
des gens qui ont un intérêt à ce que ces
molécules hla soient pulvérisés sur les
champs ce que ça rapporte énormément
d'argent
peut-être que ça arrange l'industrie
qu'on parle que ni glyphosate parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres herbicides
ils sont en jeu et le glyphosate est une
molécule qui est tombé dans le domaine
public
elle n'a plus de problème dans tout le
monde peut en produire il ya d'autres
herbicides qui sont en train d'arriver
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont de
l'ordre de l'économie dire qu'on nous
impose ces choses là
non pas parce qu'il ya un intérêt social
parce qu'un intérêt économique
[Musique]
le lac le plus vieux du monde les lacs
n'ont généralement pas plus de quinze
mille ans le baïkal à plus de 25
millions d'années
ici vivent des esprits et des divinités
bouddhiste
[Musique]
l'eau pure et transparente du lac aide
les scientifiques à résoudre des
mystères de l'univers
je vois le baïkal comme un ensemble
cohérent ça je ne savais pas à quoi
m'attendre ici ce n'est pas que je
découvre quelque chose de nouveau ici je
m'imprègne simplement de tout ce qu'il y
a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est 21h bonsoir et merci de nous
rejoindre en direct sur rt france pour
cette deuxième heure d'information tout
site voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mercredi le programme nucléaire
iranien au coeur des discussions europe
chine et russie poursuivre les
discussions à vienne avec téhéran si
tous les participants ont réaffirmé
l'importance de préserver l'accord les
tentatives de conciliation se poursuivre
pour la première fois depuis le
lancement d'une procédure contre l'iran
accusé de violer l'accord de 2015 en
inde le premier ministre appelle au
calme dans la capitale new delhi des
affrontements communautaires entre
hindous et musulmans ont fait 27 morts
et plus de 200 blessés ces violences
font suite à l'adoption d'une loi en
décembre
elle facilite l'attribution de la
citoyenneté aux réfugiés
à l'exception des musulmans
[Musique]
elle dix huitième cas de coronavirus
confirmés en france les pouces d'un
patients hospitalisés à annecy et
premier français décédé cette nuit à
paris elle cet enseignant de 60 ans de
waze faisait partie des trois nouveaux
cas détectés en france et les chefs des
partis et présidents de groupes
parlementaires sont reçus demain à
matignon pour faire un point sur la
situation
en tous les cas le match lyon juventus a
bien débuté avec dans les tribunes des
supporters italiens
c'est ce qu'a confirmé olivier ferrand
le ministre de la santé
[Musique]
réunion au sommet à vienne autour du
nucléaire iranien outre l'iran la france
le royaume uni l'allemagne la chine et
la russie ont participé à cette
rencontre
objectif préserver la corde 2015 et ce
malgré le retrait de washington en 2018
à téhéran ces cartes progressivement de
cet accord en réponse aux sanctions avec
qui lui sont imposées et l'iran réclame
le respect de tous les accords et ne
toutes les parties saillantes
nous sommes toujours ouverts à toute
initiative susceptible de garantir à
l'iran les dividendes du disciple way et
nous sommes tout à fait disposés à
annuler les mesures que nous avons
prises jusqu'à présent
en contrepartie du respect des
engagements de l'autre partie au titre
dudit cypihot et tous les autres
participants aux disciples ont confirmé
une fois de plus l'importance de cet
accord et ils soutiennent cet accord et
leurs efforts leur volonté de protéger
cet accord est de s'assurer que l'accord
le disciple reste en vie le 14 juillet
2015 un accord historique était conclue
avec l'objectif de limiter le nucléaire
iranien côté américain barack obama on
était le signataire à mais que
contient-il et pourquoi dérange-t-il le
temps donald trump précision avec grâce
d'ailleurs
un accord qui rassemble les états unis
l'union européenne dont le royaume uni
l'allemagne et la france ainsi que la
chine la russie et l'iran avant que le
texte soit paraphé les négociations ont
duré près de 21 mois
son objectif empêcher téhéran de se
doter de la bombe atomique
mais pourquoi cet accord en 1974 le pays
s'engage à le fabriquer ni à se procurer
la bombe atomique
en signant un traité de
non-prolifération en 1979 quand
l'ayatollah khomeini prend le pouvoir et
instaure la révolution islamique
les puissances occidentales ne sont plus
perçus d'un très bon oeil du côté de
téhéran le 4 novembre de cette même
année
une prise d'otages menée par des
étudiants iraniens débute à l'ambassade
des états unis
52 personnes sont concernées dont des
diplomates et des civils la prise
d'otage dur à 444 jours
la riposte des états unis ne se fait pas
attendre 12 milliards d'actifs iranien
jeudi dans la foulée sans oublier de
nombreuses autres sanctions dont un
embargo sur les armes en 1995
au niveau international on commence à se
pencher sur le cas de téhéran en 2000
agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique découvre deux sites nucléaires
iraniens ce secret malgré de nombreux
avertissements la république islamique
ne tremble pas l'union européenne et
l'onu infligent les premières sanctions
économiques en 2006 en 2013 le modéré
hassan rohani prend les rênes du pays
c'est grâce à lui que la situation
s'apaise et permet deux ans plus tard de
parvenir à l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien
quelles obligations contient-il l'iran
s'engage à diviser par deux le nombre de
ses sites à ne pas construire de
nouvelles infrastructures destinées à
l'enrichissement d'uranium pendant dix
ans et à ne pas enrichir d'uranium à
plus de 3 67%
installation de nathan ce sera le seul
site d'enrichissement d'uranium du pays
à rester en fonctionnement mais en 2017
donald 30 arrivée à la maison blanche
l'année suivante il affirme avoir la
preuve que téhéran continue de
développer l'armé nucléaire
rôtir les états unis de l'accord et
sanctionne immédiatement la république
islamique
plus de transactions financières ni
d'importation pour couronner le tout
washington place 50 banques iraniennes
sur une liste noire
commence alors un bras de fer qui
perdure jusqu'à aujourd'hui et pour en
parler nous sommes avec à nasser et m a
dit journaliste à rfi nassar et m a dit
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors on le
disait premières rencontres 1 depuis le
lancement d'une procédure contre téhéran
accusé de violer l'accord en 2015
on peut parler d'une ambiance tendue
lors de cette réunion pas en fait
à l'issue de cette rencontre les
participants ont dit que hisser sont mis
d'accord sera un certain nombre de
préoccupations communes
ils ont dit que finalement c'est ti
cette discussion qui vient juste
commencé et vont continuer et ces
discussions rappelons-le au ont lieu au
niveau des directeurs des ministères des
affaires étrangères des pays hors de
pays signataires de cet accord
et puis il n'ya pas une date butoir donc
on est au début d'un processus dont le
résultat est encore incertain vous
parliez de préoccupations qu'elles sont
elles ces préoccupations en tout cas
pour l'europe la russie et la chine
bon là
nous savons que les américains se sont
retirés en mai 2010huit cet accord on y
reviendra verront donc les européens les
russes et les chinois constate également
que les iraniens en réaction ont
commencé à mettre en question cet accord
nucléaire or cet accord nucléaire
n'existait pas dans le fait même si tous
les signataires et insisté sur le fait
qu'ils veulent toujours gardé leurs
engagements par rapport à cet accord les
européens les chinois et les rousses est
compris et crée de plus en plus que par
cette mise en cause c'est réciproque par
les américains et les iraniens
il y aura pas la courbe look nucléaire
donc le traité de non-prolifération sera
finalement mise en cause ce qui a un
coût gras av
en fait aux équilibres à l'équilibré
mondial et que finalement il y aurait un
risque d'affrontement en l'occurrence
entre les américains et des iraniens
dans une région qui était déjà déchirée
par des guerres interminables sans nom
dont va là la préoccupation principale
les européens les russes et les chinois
tentent de sauver cet accord n'en voit
pas par quel moyen
justement est-ce que européens chinois
et russes pourraient faire des
concessions à l'iran pour sauver cet
accord dans game texte que vous venez
d'évoquer la tente des iraniens tout le
monde le sait est clair ils ont demandé
aux iraniens aux chinois et russes de
leur permet de contourner les sanctions
américaines
il demande aux européens d'acheter leur
pétrole or l'europe a été la première à
intérêt entre l'importation de pétrole
iranien
ea a coupé toutes transactions bancaires
avec le régime iranien
l'euro ne fait que exécuter les
sanctions américaines
malgré elle-même certes mais est-ce que
cela change quelque chose ou égard à
l'impact car cela sur l'économie
exsangue et iranienne mais est ce que
l'europe peut proposer d'autres choses
alliant d'autres
dil malheureusement nos forces a
constaté que l'europe avec toute la
bonne volonté du monde
c'est valable également pour les russes
et les chinois ne peuvent pas aider les
iraniens à contourner les sanctions
américain ce qui fait que finalement
tout le monde et tout dans une impasse a
aggravé et que c'est un passe finalement
a rendu les américains au jour dans la
réalité le maître et du jour donc finira
finalement même le russe qui avait signé
des accords bilatéraux avec les iraniens
finalement se sont retirés de ces
accords à cause des sanctions
économiques non économiques américains à
l'endroit de régime de terrain donc on
est dans une situation très difficile
très fragile
et puis force est constater également le
régime iranien et devient de plus en
plus fragile on a constaté lors des
législatives de vendredi dernière le
taux d'abstention était énorme c'était
le taux le plus bas qui a existé depuis
l'avènement de la république islamique
on a également où les révolte de
novembre et dernière donc on a
l'impression que au napa on n'est pas en
présence d'un état en iran mais d'un et
spectre de l'état ce qui ne favorise pas
les conditions d'une entente mais ce que
ça veut dire que c'est donald trump
aujourd'hui la clé de la résolution il y
là où toujours dès le départ
la clé de cette affaire en se retirant
de l'accord nucléaire
donald tremblay à vis de
l'administration actuelle savait que
finalement l'euro la russie et la chine
ne sont d'aucun secours au régime
iranien
donc est ce d'ailleurs ils le disent
ouvertement si il y à 1 10 il se passe
entre chaque don et teyran mais force
est de constater que téhéran pour terran
un tel accord c'est l'échec total cela
signifie l'effondrement d'un système
fortement fragilisé sous le coup des
sanctions américain et sous les coups
également des contestations de plus en
plus radical au sein du pays alors en
tout cas en l'absence de conciliation
vous nous le disiez ce n'est que le
début ça va durer ya pas de date butoir
elle mais si jamais y'a pas de
conciliation entre ces pays à quoi
peut-on s'attendre
bah finalement les européens les chinois
et le rouge seront obligés de
réactualiser des sanctions ténin sonido
conseil de sécurité même si cela ne
change rien dans la réalité des choses
dans la situation actuelle du régime
iranien parce que finalement même en
l'absence de ces sanctions les sanctions
américaines à elle tout seul a rendu
exsangue l'économie iranienne a brisé le
dos de l'économie rainer un iranienne et
en étant la situation générale des
iraniens et qui sont confrontés à des
problèmes majeurs de 2,2 tout de se
procurer des médicaments délivrés tour
et ceara et c est justement quels
seraient les intérêts de l'iran comme on
doit se positionner l'iran selon vous
pour sortir du mieux possible de cette
crise économique liée à ces sanctions
américaines est ce qu'il ya une solution
est ce qu'il ya des négociations
possibles
la solution de ne me paraît pas applaudi
pour le moment c'est le constat fait par
les iraniens qui ont en fait est désisté
les zooms le vendredi dernière il
constate finalement qui sont en face
d'un régime anachronique d'un régime
irréformable frappé par une corruption
systémique mais surtout un régime
incompétent incapable de gérer les
affaires les plus courantes de pays
d'ailleurs la crise de croo navire uss
vient de le montrer
alors que les autorités n'ont pas
seulement 240 cas et 19 décès les
estimations scientifiques parlent de de
présence ont entre 18 et 50 me foutais
d'infection des personnes infectées dans
ce pays ce qui a transformé d'ores et
déjà l'iran en deuxième foyer mondial de
diffusion de ce virus qui inquiète en
fait
tout le monde donc tout cela va
fragiliser de plus en plus le régime de
téhéran
et finalement on ne sait pas à qui on
fait entendre à qui on grossit un accord
va là pourquoi je dis que tu n'as banc
tout lé monde dans une impasse est
vraiment aggravée et sans précédent
alors en 2019
il y avait un mécanisme de troc nommer
un steak ce qui a été créé par les
européens justement pour contourner les
sanctions américaines imposées à l'iran
en évitant d'utiliser le dollar est ce
que cela a fonctionné est ce que cela
fonctionne
est ce que c'est une solution à court
terme pas finalement si on en est là
aujourd'hui c'est parce que cela n'a pas
fonctionné
hinse texte qui était une invention de
l'europe pour permettre aux iraniens de
contourner les sanctions d'échangés
entre autres le pétrole est contré les
marchandises a fini par un constat est
déchets et c'est pour ça qu on est
aujourd'hui la force est de constater
également que l'euro les chinois et les
russes n'ont pas un souci tout à cet
échec
donc personnellement je ne vois pas
comment les européens les russes et les
chinoises peuvent sauver un accord qui
n'existait plus comme je le disais il ya
un instant dans l'art étant la réalité
en tous les cas pour conclure à quoi
est-ce que vous allez être attentifs
dans les prochaines semaines dans les
prochains mois après cette réunion à
venise bas vous savez en dehors de ces
problèmes de l'accord nucléaire le
régime iranien est affrontée à des
crises multiples et il ya une crise de
10 légitimité politique de discrédit
politique ce qui s'est traduit non
seulement par les comtés de contestation
et sporadique mais de plus en plus
radicale à travers tout pays mais
également le taux d'abstention major
l'eau régime iranien a dit le taux
d'abstention qui était de le seul enjeu
de cette élection était de 42% mais
c'est long l'estimation plus ré hormis
les fraudes électorales habituel
le taux de participation n'a pas dépassé
15 % donc on est en présence nos
situations de crises multiples d'impasse
et sous cette situation ne fasse ne
favorise pas en fait on y joue aux roses
à ce problème
merci beaucoup nasser et m a dit d'avoir
apporté votre éclairage sur cette
réunion qui a eu lieu aujourd'hui à
vienne je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste à rfi le bilan s'alourdit en
inde plus de 20 morts et 200 blessés
dans les violences intercommunautaires
qui frappe new delhi depuis dimanche de
nombreux quartiers de la capitale sont
le théâtre de scènes de guérilla urbaine
en cause une loi controversée sur la
citoyenneté jugé discriminatoire pour
les musulmans
les détails avec solène gaudin et rania
berrada scènes de guérilla à peine une
dizaine de kilomètres du centre de new
delhi depuis trois jours cette partie de
la capitale indienne est le théâtre de
violents affrontements
ce qui était au départ des
manifestations contre une loi sur la
citoyenneté jugé discriminatoire s'est
transformée en lutte armée entre
nationalistes hindous et musulmans
véhicules magasins et maisons incendiées
une situation qui pousse les habitants à
fuir craignant pour leur vie
les hôtels ferment les usines ferment
qu'allons nous faire
les gens m'appellent de mon village ils
sont tous inquiets
qu'est ce qu'on va faire il vaut mieux
partir que rester ici pourquoi
voudrions-nous mourir ici les gens
s'entretuent des balles pleuvent
j'ai vu des affrontements dans le
quartier depuis ce matin et je quitte la
maison pour cela et une population qui
dénonce l'inaction des forces de l'ordre
depuis hier nous demandons à la police
d'appliquer un couvre-feu d'envoyer des
renforts mais personne n'est venu
il n'y a que trois policiers on a appelé
la police plusieurs fois depuis chang
bague les gens scandaient gloire au
seigneur ram est rentré dans le quartier
mais la police ne nous a pas du tout
aidé
pour tenter de contenir l'embrasement un
couvre-feu a été imposé dans ses
quartiers depuis hier soir le premier
ministre narindra maudit a appelé au
calme ce matin sur twitter la paix et
l'harmonie sont au coeur de notre
philosophie
j'invite mes soeurs et frères de délier
à maintenir la paix et la fraternité en
tout temps il est important qu'il y ait
calme et que la normalité soit rétabli
ou plutôt parmi les responsables indiens
des voix s'élèvent pour condamner la
passivité des autorités
la présidente du parti du congrès sonia
gandhi réclament la démission du
ministre de l'intérieur et pour en
parler nous sommes avec claude
blanchemaison ancien ambassadeur de
france en inde et expert en relations
internationales claude blanchemaison
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france le président
américain était osé oran en inde
il y avait 24 heures après cette visite
finalement qu' on tire le plus de
bénéfices le premier ministre indien
maudit où le président américain troy
finalement je crois que le compte y est
pour chacun à chacun d'entre eux
simplement peut-être si je peux
m'exprimer en terme sportif je dirais
avantage a maudit avantages d'un maudit
parce que finalement c'est lui qui a
organisé ce voyage qui s'est avéré un
voyage triomphal pour le président
américain
et monsieur moody a pu démontrer par là
c'est capacité diplomatique
sa capacité à nouer des liens personnels
avec les grands de ce monde
il a déjà fait d'ailleurs auparavant
parce que il a fait la même chose avec
jean ping le président chinois avec
pourtant lequel il ya des différends
notamment y compris les différends
frontaliers mais il avait invité au
kerala cette fois là alors que pour
trame cesson et l'état qu'il a dirigé
pendant dix ans avec dans sa capitale à
mais la balle et c'était évidemment
encore plus extraordinaire mais narendra
modi l'a fait aussi
avec monsieur poutine on rencontrait
vladivostok et puis avec le président
français monsieur macron en venant en
france et en assistant l'invitation du
président français à la dernière journée
du g7 de biarritz et à chaque fois il a
su nouer des liens personnels alors en
plus effectivement il y là il a fait ses
emplettes militaire c'est-à-dire qu'il a
acheté pour 3 milliards d'hélicoptères
d'attac maritime
mais le sans préjudice de ce qu'ils
achètent par ailleurs à la france des
rafales à israël beaucoup d'armement et
à la russie qui est le fournisseur
historique d'armement et par ailleurs je
pense que narendra modi avait bien
compris que monsieur trump ne viendrait
pas perturber la politique intérieure
qu'il mène et d'ailleurs il l'a il a
confirmé que les affaires intérieures
indiennes et ne voulait pas s'en mêler
qu'il s'agisse du cachemire ou qu'il
s'agisse de ce qui se passe actuellement
à propos d'une loi sur les réfugiés
politiques qui peuvent acquérir la
nationalité indienne
sauf les musulmans alors le premier
ministre euh maudits vous nous en parler
dans quelle situation il est aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent au fond je
pense qu'ils cherchent à avoir une
diplomatie extrêmement ouverte
extrêmement diversifiée on pourrait dire
une diplomatie tous azimuts y compris
avec le puissant voisin chinois avec
lequel il ya des différends et dans le
fond les problèmes ne subsiste de façon
à ces irréductibles qu'avec le pakistan
à cause de la sphère du cachemire et du
mouvement qu'il a faits qui d'ailleurs
c'était des décisions qui figurait dans
son programme au mois d'août dernier il
a changé les statuts du cachemire
il en a fait un territoire de l'union
qui est directement administrées par des
lits et
avec des restrictions aux communications
au liberté d'aller et de venir qui sont
toujours en place au cachemire les
journalistes peuvent pas se rendre
librement au cachemire et puis toujours
dans son programme
cette loi sur le statut des réfugiés qui
peuvent acquérir la nationalité indienne
de façon assez rapide à condition qu'ils
ne soient pas musulman et puis un
recensement qui aura lieu l'année
prochaine tous les dix ans et un
recensement nahd mais les gens sont un
petit peu inquiet parce qu'effectivement
dans ce recensement il y aura sans doute
une mention sur la religion et sur la
date d'arrivée en ahl et compte tenu des
problèmes administratifs de ce pays
il n'est pas sûr que les musulmans
puissent trouver toujours les pièces
justificatives
alors on a vu les violences actuellement
qui se déroulent dans le pays
l'attitude des forces de l'ordre comment
est-ce que vous l'expliquer je pense que
les forces de l'ordre elles de bissau
aux instructions qu'elle reçoive et
probablement puisqu'il s'agissait en
grande partie de désordres suscités par
des milices intégristes hindouistes et
ils ont dans un premier temps en tout
cas laissé faire alors aujourd'hui c'est
terminé puisqu'il ya un couvre-feu et
que le préfet de police du territoire de
delhi a donné des instructions
naturellement pour que tout cela cesse
et puis on a entendu tout à l'heure dans
votre reportage que narendra modi
lui-même avait appelé au calme avaient
appelé à la réconciliation alors d'un
hameau dit d'ailleurs ne tient jamais
des propos très durs vis-à-vis des
musulmans
il est 7h à son ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur ameet shah qui est son compère
de longue date avec qui il a dirigé
l'état du gujarat qui a été président du
bjp ce parti hindouiste nationaliste et
qui lui tient des propos alors carrément
aussi aux musulmans donc si un jour les
choses se passaient trop mal
eh bien je pense que monsieur moody
pourrait laisser tomber désavoué son
ministre de l'intérieur
alors justement avec ses propos quelles
sont les perspectives de l'avenir de
l'inde
est ce que le pays est en train de
s'isoler justement avec les pays
musulmans
et justement grâce à sa diplomatie tous
azimuts
monsieur maudit permet a permis à l'inde
l'éviter c'est également là il y avait
sur les choses ne vont pas bien avec le
pakistan mais pour le reste il a passé
presque une semaine aux nations unies au
mois de septembre
il a vu toutes les délégations musulmane
qui étaient là pendant la semaine où les
chefs d'état de gouvernement étaient là
étaient à l'onu et il a réussi à réduire
la difficulté
un mois après avoir fait ce changement
de statut
ap ap à avoir c'est sur ce genre statut
au cachemire lorsque le pakistan a
demandé avec l'appui de la chine que la
question soit évoquée au conseil de
sécurité la russie a très vite mis le
holà et le conseil de sécurité n'a
adopté aucune résolution
donc effectivement cinquième puissance
économique du monde
la développe son influence économique
elle développe aussi son influence
culturelle et il est peu probable que la
situation actuelle provoque soit des
sanctions soient des difficultés pour
l'avenir merci beaucoup claude
blanchemaison d'avoir partagé votre
analyse sur notre plateau je rappelle
que vous êtes expert en relations
internationales mais également ancien
ambassadeur en inde
recep tayyip erdogan exclu de faire le
moindre pas en arrière face à bachar
al-assad à idlib le président turc que
maintient son ultimatum et ordonne à
damas de se retirer de certaines zones a
et lib avant la fin de la semaine
des déclarations qui interviennent alors
que doit se tenir ce jour une rencontre
turquie russie pour un nouveau round de
négociations
nous ne ferons pas le moindre pas en
arrière nous repousserons le régime
syrien
au delà des frontières que nous avons
fixé une escalade des tensions en syrie
qui inquiète les européens dans une
tribune publiée dans le quotidien le
monde les chefs de la diplomatie de 14
pays de l'union européenne ont appelé la
russie et la turquie à une désescalade
parmi les signataires le ministre
français des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian ou encore son homologue
allemand heico masse nous appelons la
russie à poursuivre les négociations
avec la turquie afin d'aboutir à une
désescalade à idlib et de contribuer à
une solution politique
nous sommes parfaitement lucide sur la
présence de groupes radicaux à idlib ne
prendront jamais à la légère le problème
du terrorisme nous le combattons avec
détermination mais la lutte contre le
terrorisme ne peut pas ne doit pas
justifier les violations massives du
droit international humanitaire et dans
quelques instants nous parlerons du
coronavirus sa propagation se poursuit
en europe notamment en italie avec 374
carré 12 morts en france un dix huitième
cas a été confirmé à l'épousé d'un
patients hospitalisés à annecy
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
c'est le sentiment que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes poussent le fait de vivre
avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme une machine un organisme
et pour faire partie de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps qu'on vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres et je pense que
ces genres de projets qui se fait pas
tout seul dans son coin on est dans un
truc vraiment de coopération de partage
de partage
[Musique]
mais vous
les blanchons les bébés phoques du
groenland naissent sur la banquise de la
mer blanche
tout au long du xxème siècle les bébés
phoques ont été chassés pour leur
fourrure blanche comme neige
depuis que la chasse aux phoques est
interdite en russie il n'y a que les
touristes qui viennent voir ces animaux
à l'état sauvage
mais ces petits seront ils toujours en
sécurité
[Musique]
les chefs-d'oeuvre de la peinture sont
comme des livres ouverts sur les siècles
passés
les contempler ces découvrir le regard
que portent les artistes sur leur époque
[Musique]
il est un thème qui a toujours eu une
place à part dans l'histoire de l'art
c'est celui de l'enfance
et vous
[Applaudissements]
que le regard de l'artiste a changé
entre cet enfant iconique peint sous les
traits de jésus par jean fouquet
et cet enfant couvert de toute la
tendresse de sa mère peint par elisabeth
vigée lebrun
entre le regard triste de cette jeune
fille contraint de vendre ses charmes
dans les rues de londres et
l'insouciance de cet enfant à qui le
suisse félix vallotton donne la liberté
de ne même pas regardé le peintre
de l'allemand dürer aux flamands
revendiquent de l'espagnol velasquez au
moderne renoir miro et picasso à travers
toute l'europe du moyen âge au 20e
siècle les grands maîtres de la peinture
n'ont cessé de représenter les enfants
selon les canons de leur époque
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france il est
21h30 heure française et ont un des buts
avec le coronavirus et un dix huitième
cas confirmés en france il s'agit de
l'épousé d'un patients hospitalisés à
annecy
l annonce a été faite tout à l'heure par
le ministre de la santé olivier vers en
cette nuit un homme de 60 ans est décédé
à paris il faisait partie des trois
nouveaux cas confirmés sur le territoire
français il ne s'était pas rendue dans
une zone d'exposition à un risque le
ministre de la santé olivier vers en a
fait le point il y à quelques minutes
son l'écoutent
il y à un 18e patient qui a été
diagnostiqué positif pour le coronavirus
il s'agit de l'épousé du patient
actuellement hospitalisés à annecy et la
détection systématique du virus a permis
d'identifier que cette épouse du
patients hospitalisés à annecy était
positive pour le corona virus son état
de santé n'est pas inquiétant
mais elle est évidemment hospitalisés et
isolé au même titre que les autres
malades
il n'y a pas eu d'autres diagnostics
positifs aujourd'hui pour le coronavirus
à laquelle à l'heure à laquelle je vous
parle la france continue dans sa
stratégie visant à freiner la diffusion
du virus
face aux risques épidémiques je le redis
ce soir il n'y a pas d'épidémie en
france nous faisons toujours face à des
cas des patients isolés que l'on s'est
expliquée par un voyage ou par un
contact avec une personne qui a été elle
même contaminer l'homme décédé la nuit
dernière à paris avait donc 60 ans il
était enseignant dans un collège de
l'oise à les hôpitaux se prépare face à
une éventuelle épidémie tandis qu'à nice
et la ville a décidé d'annuler le
carnaval françois tisci et mutsch
il avait 60 ans et était hospitalisé à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris
l'homme avait été testé en urgence mardi
dans un état gravissime
originaire de l'oise il avait été
d'abord admis à l'hôpital de creil qui a
décidé de déclencher le plan blanc
conséquence toutes les opérations non
urgentes qui étaient prévus sont
annulées et tout le personnel
hospitalier est en alerte et mobilisable
très rapidement survenait à découvrir de
nouveaux cas enseignant dans un collège
à crépy en valois
il ne s'était pas rendue dans une zone
d'exposition à risque mais la préfecture
écarte toute contagion pour ses élèves
et ses collègues dès lors qu'il a été
prise en charge
eh bien il n'a plus été en contact à
partir du 10 février avec des élèves ou
avec des parents d'élèves des collègues
enseignants
donc ce risque est écarté et puis nous
sommes le 26 février le de ce délai de
14 jours personne ne s'étant signalé
comme ayant des symptômes qui pourraient
être assimilées à une contagion par le
cor grands navires us
eh bien il ya tout lieu de penser qu' il
n'y a plus de personnes contaminées
ce mercredi midi à l'issue du conseil
des ministres la porte parole du
gouvernement si bête ndiaye l'assurent
il n'y a toujours pas d'épidémie en
france et tout est mis en oeuvre pour y
faire face comme ici à l'institut
méditerranéen fiction de marseille
chercheurs médecins et laborantins sont
sur le pied de guerre pour réagir face à
une éventuelle pandémie de coronavirus
aussi s'avérait qu'un patient soit
porteur du corona chinois ou en cas de
patients qui présentent une forme sévère
d'infection qui justifie son
hospitalisation
eh bien il est transféré immédiatement
au troisième étage de l'ia chez dans le
service de maladies infectieuses où il
sera admis par l'intermédiaire d'un
un ascenseur dédié donc il ne croisera
pas ce patient aucun soignant ni aucun
autre patient et il sera donc installée
dans une chambre dépression est temps
que cette chambre est bien dû seront
admises fait les soins éventuellement
l'administration de chloroquine ci
s'avère que c'est un virus pour un
navire chinois ou d'autres traitements
il se passera dans cette chambre jusqu'à
ce qu'ils soient jugés non contagieux à
nice situe à moins de 50 kilomètres de
la frontière italienne
la ville a décidé d'annuler les derniers
jours du carnaval à titre préventif
il devait se dérouler jusqu'à samedi
ce jeudi matin le premier ministre
edouard philippe recevra les chefs de
partis représentés au parlement
les présidents de groupes parlementaires
et les présidents d'assemblée afin de
faire un point sur la situation liée à
l'épidémie la propagation du coronavirus
se poursuit donc en europe outre
atlantique donald trump accuse lui ses
adversaires démocrates de créer la
panique qui autour de l'épidémie
1 la ville de nice on vient de le voir
annuler son carnaval celle de menton
annuler quand elle la fête du citron par
précaution un mais le match de football
you jean marc jullion juventus a lui été
maintenu alors quelle attitude adopter
face à l'épidémie
un certain événement méritent ils d'être
maintenue à tout prix le principe de
précaution est il suffisamment appliqués
pour en parler nous sommes avec bruno
gollnisch membre du bureau politique du
rassemblement national bruno gollnisch
bonsoir bonsoir on va vous entendre dans
un instant mais avant je vous propose
d'écouter olivier ferrand le ministre de
la santé à propos du soffin de ce fameux
match de football qui a fait débat
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de malades
identifiées à turin il n'y a pas de
malades identifiées dans la région du
pjak du piémont et turin se situe à 200
kilomètres des zones dites à risque
italienne 200 km nous attendons ce soir
à lyon quelques 3000 supporters qui
viennent de la région du piémont et qui
viennent de turin il n'y a donc pas de
données scientifiques de données
médicales de données épidémiologiques
c'est une décision qui
est assise sur la concertation des
experts et validé par la direction
générale de la santé
il n'y a pas lieu d'empêcher ces
personnes de se rendre
un match de football alors bien entendre
le ministre de la santé
pas de données scientifiques pour
interdire ce fameux match de football ça
a été une question qui a été posée toute
la journée est ce que vous comprenez
cette levée de boucliers contre la venue
de ses supporters italiens aujourd'hui à
lyon oui je la comprends tout en
manifestant la plus grande sympathie à
l'égard de de l'italie et des italiens
je comprends que cela paraisse quand
même assez incohérent que d'une part
l'état par la voix du ministre de
l'éducation demande que les enfants
français qui reviennent d'italie du nord
restent chez eux n'aille pas à l'école
afin d'éviter tout risque de contagion
au cas où ils seraient tous même
contaminé et qu'on laisse venir 3000
adultes venant d'italie du nord à lyon
alors le gentil je viens d'entendre
seulement race que ce qu'a dit le
ministre que turin serait à 200
kilomètres des foyers d'infection c'est
vrai que turin et dans la capitale du
piémont et pas de la lombardie qui a été
davantage touchées mais j'ai pas
l'impression que ce sont les distances
soit aussi importante que le
ministre le dit je crois que c'est je
crois que c'est inconséquent je crois
que c'est imprudent
c'est un prudent tout en plus que voilà
un match de football soit peut être
reportée gens quand même que ce soit une
question vitale
on imagine néanmoins qu'il a été
conseillé par des spécialistes qui s'est
renseigné alors comment vous expliquez
vous au fond ce que vous dites comme un
deux poids deux mesures finalement oui
j'ai observé commun de prévoir très
clairement qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures et que c'était pas une preuve de
cohérence au sein au sein du
gouvernement
je moi je crois que nous touchons du
doigt le fait que la mondialisation n'a
pas que des effets heureux que les
échanges internationaux doivent être
contrôlés non pas nous ne demandons nous
n'avons jamais demandé au rassemblement
national anciennement au front national
contrairement à la caricature qui te
fait de nous que d'isoler complètement
la france du reste du monde c'est cette
caricature grossière de nos positions et
absurde
ce que nous demandons c'est que les
frontières jouent leur rôle de deux
paires de perméabilité en laissant
entrer ce qui est bon et éventuellement
freinant ce qui ne ce qui ne l'est pas
or en période précisément une période
comme celle ci il conviendrait
d'augmenter les contrôles il est quand
même tout à fait paradoxal que kylie est
à l'intérieur même des de l'italie des
zones qu'ils soient complètement isolée
du reste du pays autrement dit l'italie
a recréé une frontière artificielle
autour de certaines de ces
agglomérations et il n'y a aucun
contrôle entre la frontière italienne et
la frontière française
en tout cas on a vu a eu un petit
imbroglio aujourd'hui quant à la
décision de jouer ou non ce mal gérard
collomb le maire de lyon
a dit qu'il s'était au ministre de
décider on a vu de son côté le maire de
nice lui annuler le carnaval
pour vous qu'est-ce qui doit décider
dans ces cas-là du maintien ou non d'un
événement dans le contexte de ce corps à
des virus moi si j'avais été maire de
lyon gt gt je n'étais que conseiller
municipal dans cette ville les
parlementaires bien sûr si j'avais été
maire de lyon j'aurais pris mes
responsabilités et j'aurais pris mes
responsabilités
le maire a des pouvoirs de police
j'aurai donc pris la décision
effectivement de reporter le match
et si cette décision avait été contestée
par le ministère de tutelle
eh bien il leur aurait d'abord tenu de
saisir la juridiction administrative et
on aurait vu ce que ce que ce que disait
ce que diraient les juridictions qui
savez moi je pense que les pouvoirs de
police du maire
le tout à fait suffisant pour permettre
de prendre la décision
monsieur que l'on a tiré le parapluie
parce qu'il ne veut pas de se rendre
impopulaire auprès des fans de football
je suppose parce questions économiques
derrière selon vous comment une question
économique également derrière où il met
enfin encore une fois un match ça peut
être reporté mais a leaké sur l'économie
très important d'ailleurs le là on vient
d'apprendre le je crois que ce sont vos
confrères du figaro qui rendent publique
une étude extrêmement intéressante faite
par une promotion de jeunes officiers de
marine qui sont en ce moment à l'école
de guerre j'ai fait une école de
perfectionnement à mi carrière et qui
tire les conséquences de cet aveu cette
affaire du coronavirus et qui tire la
sonnette d'alarmé qui disent nos
frontières doivent être protégés y
compris nos frontières maritimes
je rappelle quand même le l'épisode des
dégâts même princess qui étaient
absolument dramatiques
je crois que c'est encore une fois c'est
conforme à ce principe de précaution de
tôle rebat les oreilles ne vois pas
tellement les applications en la
circonstance alors le numéro deux du
ministre de la santé lui a dit
qu'effectivement les réseaux sociaux
aussi favoriser un petit peu ce côté
panique est ce que finalement les
réseaux sociaux c'est pas là encore le
premier ennemi du du gouvernement avec
des réseaux sociaux son premier ennemi
des pouvoirs établis ça c'est sûr mais
les réseaux sociaux sont beaucoup moins
nocif que les mensonges d'état les
réseaux s'est passé pas je pourrais
citer des mensonges d'état notamment
brrr ceux qui ont donné lieu à la
deuxième guerre d'irak qui ont tué des
conséquences dramatiques
il peut se dire des bêtises sur les
réseaux sociaux mais comme comme
beaucoup peuvent s'exprimer sur les
réseaux sociaux ces bêtises ont
généralement leurs contreparties mais
c'est toujours la même litanie je me
souviens très bien quand j'étais jeune
parlementaire il ya eu le
l'arrivée du sida on connaissait très
mal cette maladie nous avions eu des
avis médicaux et nous avons dit à
l'assemblée nationale attention cette
maladie est une maladie grave il faut
prévoir
il faut prévoir des centres de soins
spécialisés il faut prévoir
éventuellement des possibilités de
dépistage est aussitôt l'ensemble de nos
adversaires nous a dit et compris le
ministère mais vous voulez agité des
peurs voulait agité des peurs pour une
cité dnc toujours le même discours
dès que ça at elle écrit quand même une
chose c'est qu'en france selon le mot du
de chez le célèbre mot de chamfort il ya
déjà quelques quelques siècles on laisse
en paix les incendiaires mais on
persécute ce qui sonne le tocsin
voilà je crois qu'il n'y a pas gcp il
n'est pas indigne de la part des réseaux
sociaux de s'inquiéter alors bruno
gollnisch vous propose d'écouter
plusieurs politiques que eux aussi ont
réagi à la présence des supporters
italiens au match de ligue des champions
entre l'olympique lyonnais et la
juventus
comment peut-on confinés pendant 14
jours les français revenant d'italie
alors même qu'on laisse ce soir 3000
supporters italiens assister à un match
de foot à lyon venant en plus de turin
c'est absurde
appliquons le principe de précaution
avec daniel casa riant et jean louis
touraine nous avons écrit au ministre de
la santé afin d'interdire la venue des
3000 supporters italiens au match ol
juin à lyon ce soir
cette mesure de précaution s'impose dans
le contexte actuel afin d'éviter la
propagation du coronavirus on prend le
virus dans ce genre de grands
rassemblements
quand il ya promiscuité personnellement
je ne le ferai pas à un moment donné
ce qui est important c'est la prévention
dont convient d'entendre un des
personnalités de droite a encore étonné
par le fait que ce match c'est plus
jouer je vais vous citer ségolène royal
est pour elle elle dit peut-être que le
gouvernement a des informations qu en
tout cas le public n'a pas
sans tomber dans les théories farfelues
ou complotistes est ce qu'on peut dire
que toute transparence pour vous en tout
cas respecté sur le sujet du corps aux
navires ne ne vois pas comment on peut
gouvernement peut avoir des informations
s'agissant d'un virus qui par définition
est invisible et dont on nous dit
d'ailleurs qu'il est contagieux dès la
période d'incubation
c'est à dire qu'il peut être transmis
par des personnes qui n'ont aucun
symptôme de la maladie
par conséquent qui que vous soyez le
pape ministre président de la république
professeur de médecine vous ne pouvez
pas dire ce qu'il en est le la seule
information que qu'a donnée le ministre
que je viens d'entendre sur votre
antenne là c'est que turin était à bonne
distance des foyers d'infection jusqu'à
présent constaté en italie ça me paraît
tout de même un peu léger je ne vous le
cache pas est ce que la france selon
vous elle est mieux armé que d'autres
pays c'est en tout cas ce qu'on entend
on entend souvent effectivement qu'on
est prêt à gérer une éventuelle épidémie
alors que l'on voit aussi à côté le
personnel hospitalier réclamer plus de
moyens depuis bien sûr moi non mais ça
de la situation du personnel hospitalier
et cela est extrêmement difficile et ça
mais je crois que la france et malgré
tout mieux armé que certains pays ou
d'où le système hospitalier texte est
extrêmement rudimentaire et moi
j'attends avec beaucoup d'inquiétude et
d'angoissé pour les populations de ces
deux secteurs par exemple au moment où
cette épidémie arrivera si elle arrive
et je pense qu'elles risquent d'arriver
par exemple en afrique
je pense que ça risque d'être là où les
moyens de dépistage et de soins sont
quand même extrêmement
rudimentaire nasser dans moins dans
certaines zones bon la france et est
mieux armé à ce titre que d'autres mais
encore une fois
moi je joue quand j'entends le préfet
des alpes maritimes par exemple qui en
réponse à un certain nombre de
personnalités politiques dont des
concurrents ou des adversaires de ma
formation je pense à monsieur ciotti par
exemple bon qui le souhaitaient et qu'un
prix vous avez rappelé que les maires
ont pris leurs responsabilités
à menton à nice qui souhaitait davantage
de contrôles aux frontières le préfet a
répondu c'est quoi ça servirait à rien
de contrôler les frontières puisque de
toute façon les italiens peuvent passer
le veut passer par roissy le mais le
bref et ignorent qu on peut aussi
contrôler les arrivées à roissy bien
quand même là tout un appareil policier
il ya je crois que je crois qu'il ya
plus de mille policiers à roissy bon on
peut on peut mettre sur pied des
contrôles élémentaire alors une
objection que l'on fait aussi souvent
dire mais les contrôles ça sert à rien
parce que quand les gens passent ils
peuvent être contaminés ils présentent
pas de symptômes
etc il est certain que aucun contrôle
n'est absolu vers la preuve c'est que la
contamination était allumée en italie
alors que l'italie avait interrompu les
liaisons aériennes avec la chine mais il
est évident il est néanmoins évident
aussi que - ou contrôler plus où donner
de chance à l'épidémie en tous les cas
pour conclure deux mâts edouard philippe
convoque neuf ministres et secrétaires
d'état pour faire un point justement sur
le kono coronavirus les chefs des partis
deux groupes parlementaires sont
également conviés pour faire le un point
sur la situation
c'est le signe de quoi un pour vous
c'est le signe d'un début de crise je je
je pense que c'est
c'est une mesure de bon sens ça prouve
quand même que le gouvernement n'est pas
tout à fait assurée de ses arrières et
il nous fait bien en démocratie de
consulter j'espère c'est pas une
consultation purement de façade de
consulter les représentants de toutes
dépassé pas le forces politiques oui et
des groupes parlementaires de
l'assemblée nationale
merci beaucoup bruno d'avoir accepté
notre invitation je rappelle que vous
êtes membre du bureau
politique du rassemblement national
après un faux départ lundi en raison de
la grève des avocats le procès de
françois et pénélope fillon a débuté cet
après-midi à paris trois ans après
l'éclatement du scandale des emplois
présumés fictifs
l'ancien premier ministre et son épouse
ont comparu cet après midi devant la
justice on fait le point avec notre
reporter bassin chebbi premier jour du
procès du couple fillon après un renvoi
par leur avocat suite au blocage à la
grève de leurs confrères c'était il y a
deux jours aujourd'hui s'est ouvert le
premier jour de ce procès le couple
fillon comparaît pour des soupçons
d'emplois fictifs et détournement de
fonds publics la salle était comble de
journalistes mais aussi et de badauds
venus assister à sept premiers jours à
ce premier jour d'audience le couple
fillon était accompagné de marc joulaud
une science qui a été ouverte par la
présidente du tribunal correctionnel qui
est revenu sur les faits qu'on reproche
aux couples fillon emplois fictifs
auprès de monsieur joulaud pour pénélope
fillon aussi les emplois fictifs de
leurs enfants quand monsieur fillon
était sénateur et ce entre 2005 et 2007
ils sont revenus
également sur l'emploi de pénélope
fillon comme conseillère littéraire à la
revue des deux mondes auprès de marc de
lacharrière et ans pour le ré empoché
135 mille euros marc de lacharrière
aurait également fait un prêt au couple
fillon de 50000 euros après qu'ils
n'arrivaient pas été a déclaré voilà les
faits qu'on l'a ému nérée la présidente
du tribunal correctionnel pour cette
première fois pardon journée d'audience
du couple fillon
les avocats du couple sont intervenus
bien sûr première partie de leurs
plaidoiries
ils sont revenus sur les délais de
prescription qui selon eux ne sont pas
respectées maître pierre cornut gentille
les arguments étaient entendus bien sûr
par le procureur général de la
république financières et les revenus
sur ces délais de prescription qui
n'avaient pas lieu dans ce procès il a
même pointé la victimisation de la part
comme stratégie pardon de la part de la
défense voilà comment s'est terminé
cette première journée d'audience une
audience qui devrait reprendre
l'entraînement demain à partir de 13h30
françois fillon n'a pas été le seul
premier ministre mise
examen sous la vème république depuis
1981 presque un ancien premier ministre
sur deux a déjà été convoqué par les
tribunaux regarder
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
les débats sur la réforme des retraites
s'enlise lors de son point presse
hebdomadaire si bête
ndiaye a fustigé l'obstruction faite par
l'opposition à la porte parole du
gouvernement estime que le débat
parlementaire doit avoir les jeux ne
désespère pas que les uns et les autres
puissent revenir à la raison et décidé
faire le choix d'offrir un spectacle de
meilleure qualité si j'ose dire à nos
concitoyens car au fond à quoi sert un
débat parlementaire
un débat parlementaire permet d'enrichir
un texte qui est proposée par le
gouvernement enrichir évidemment par des
amendements de sa propre majorité mais
aussi et ça a été le cas sur la plupart
des textes de lois qui ont été examinés
depuis cette mandature de 2,2 comment
dire d'amendements qui viennent de nos
oppositions et donc l'idée est bien de
faire en sorte que le texte initial
présenté par le gouvernement soit un
texte qui soit enrichi et qui reflète le
débat parlementaire
les avocats maintiennent la pression sur
le gouvernement concernant la réforme
des retraites ils ont manifesté devant
l'assemblée nationale pour dénoncer la
modification de régime de retraite et
l'absence d' écoute du ministère de la
justice ait les robes noires pointe le
doublement de leurs cotisations et
craignent de voir un grand nombre de
cabinets mettre la clé sous la porte
je vous propose d'en écouter quelques
années on proteste contre le projet de
loi de réforme des retraites parce que
ce projet va faire que la moitié des
cabinets vont fermer en sainte famille
c'est plus de la moitié des cabinets qui
vont fermer parce que le gouvernement va
doubler nos cotisations etc cette
réforme des retraites
le doublement de nos cotisations
implique que tous les avocats qui
s'occupe notamment des personnes les
plus faibles des plus démunis et qui ont
donc des revenus les plus faibles aussi
vont devoir fermer leurs cabinets et les
justiciables encore une fois les plus
les plus fragiles qui vont se trouver
pénaliser outre les avocats c'est pas
simplement une manifestation
corporatiste des avocats c'est aussi
pour une certaine idée de la justice du
service public de la justice auxquelles
les avocats concours que nous
manifestent pas c'est une profession
dont maintenant la france s'aperçoit
parce que jusqu'à présent on vivait sur
l'idée un peu surfaite d'une profession
nantis est la profession d'avocat est la
profession la plus pauvre du droit elle
a la majorité des avocats perçoivent un
revenu moyen de 40000 euros par an sur
des exercices totalement libéraux donc à
leur charge et ne n'a pas du tout les
clés les capacités financières de
résister à un doublement des charges et
à une réduction de l'art de l'art de la
retraite future
les avocats également mobilisés ce soir
à versailles le rendez vous a été donné
devant la cour d'appel pour un trajet
illuminé aux flambeaux nous faisons le
point sur cette action avec notre
reporter lit la femme ouzou depuis
versailles les avocats maintiennent le
cap ils étaient une centaine à s'être
donnés rendez vous devant la cour
d'appel de versailles pour une marche
aux flambeaux en direction du château de
versailles
et oui semaines déjà qui la défendent
bec et ongles leur régime autonome
qu'ils estimaient être menacée par cette
réforme je propose de les écouter
l'idée c'est pas forcément de déranger
c'est d'être vu l'idée c'est d'eux que
les gens sachent que quelles sont nos
revendications et que nos revendications
ne sont pas celles de nantes il y
protège une espèce de trésor de guerre
on entend ça à longueur de journée c'est
insupportable notre combat n'est pas
celui là nous avons un régime
indépendant depuis
grosso modo le début des années 50
on pourrait peut-être nous laisser
tranquilles on a réussi on en a on a
réglé ce régime de manière autonome de
manière satisfaisante par les avocats et
pour les avocats
on a envie de dire au gouvernement plus
aujourd'hui au parlement
laissez nous tranquilles avec notre
régime de retraite qui ne coûte rien à
personne et rapporte c'est le principe
de notre profession c'est notre
engagement d'avocats on ne cède pas
jusqu'au bout nous menons le combat et
tant que le gouvernement n'aura pas
compris que c'est une impasse de
conduire c'est le projet de réforme de
la caisse autonome des avocats nous
poursuivrons la lutte la solidarité les
avocats nous n'avons pas de leçons à
recevoir à ce niveau là car notre
profession depuis la nuit des temps aide
les plus impécunieux
dans le cadre de toutes les permanences
que nous effectuions et puis surtout
notre caisse de retraite autonome
reverse chaque année 100 millions au
régime général aux autres caisses
déficitaires ils ont prévu dans les
jours à venir des actions au niveau
local mais aussi national et tous ceux
avec qui nous avons parlé aujourd'hui
nous ont dit qu'ils ne voulaient pas de
modification de ce projet mais tout
simplement le retrait pur et simple de
la réforme des retraites
c'est la fin de cette émission proche un
point sur l'actualité dans cinq minutes
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable de nos
soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant que
peuvent faire un peu plus de 5000
militaires français à l'efficacité
certes reconnu sur une zone aussi vaste
même renforcé par cinq mille soldats
promis par les pays vieux 500
c'est là où les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
le wiki geoffroy deux frères animé par
leur passion pour l'eau ont décidé
d'emprunter les routes de la soie sur
les traces des premiers échanges entre
les civilisations
en quatre mois de la chine à paris il
parcourt sur leur side car plus de 15000
kilomètres à travers l'asie centrale et
l'asie mineure pour revivre l'évolution
du commerce mondial et son impact sur la
ressource en chef a lancé je ferais que
ce que je sois tu es un gros bout on est
des êtres humains
je vous emmène découvrir les robots les
plus high tech qui vont bientôt sortir
de leur laboratoire pour rentrer dans
nos maisons
non
[Musique]
l'ère des robots approche nous avons
l'opportunité de pouvoir changer le
monde
ceux-ci excitant ils vont changer notre
manière de nous divertir d'apprendre le
communiqué en fait il y avait changé
notre vie
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui pousse tout simplement un
apnéiste à vouloir touchées les abymes
le but ultime c'est pas forcément de
gagner des médailles welsh podium c'est
d'arriver à gérer ses émotions dans un
certain environnement et c'est un
univers qui nous permet justement
d'aller encore plus loin dans cet état
d'introspection et de travail sur le
corps et aussi sur l'esprit plus on va
être dans l'instant présent plus on va
être capable de gérer ce qu'on en a à
faire est concentré sur ce que l'on fait
c'est ta confiance et la capacité à
vivre l'instant présent à être connectés
que sur ce qui se passe sur les sons sur
le toucher sur le ressenti et ça nous
pousse dans les retranchements à changer
des choses dans notre propre vie en
dehors de l'apnée
[Musique]
dix huitième cas de coronavirus
confirmés en france elle épouse d'un
patients hospitalisés à annecy et
premier français décédé s'est tenu à
paris elle cet enseignant de 60 ans de
l'oise faisait partie des trois nouveaux
cas détectés en france à les chefs de
partis et présidents de groupes
parlementaires sont reçus demain à
matignon pour faire un point sur la
situation
en tous les cas le match lyon juventus a
bien eu lieu avec dans les tribunes des
supporters italiens
elle c'est ce qu'a confirmé olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé
le programme nucléaire iranien au coeur
des discussions
europe chine et russie poursuivre les
discussions à vienne avec qpr en est où
les parties ont réaffirmé l'importance
de préserver l'accord
les tentatives de conciliation se
poursuivent pour la première fois depuis
le lancement d'une procédure contre
l'iran accusé de violer l'accord de 2015
aux etats unis trois cadres du parti
démocrate réclame à l'administration
trump des sanctions contre moscou en
cause une hotte du renseignement il est
fait par de soi-disant interférences
russe dans la campagne présidentielle
américaine de 2000 20 mai la
présentation de cette note serait je
cite ou peu de l'aveu même de
responsables à la sécurité nationale
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france 18e
cas de coronavirus confirmés dans le
pays il s'agit de l'épousé d'un patients
hospitalisés à annecy est cette nuit un
homme de 60 ans est décédé à paris il
faisait partie des trois nouveaux cas
confirmés sur le territoire français ne
ce jeudi matin le premier ministre
edouard philippe recevra les chefs de
parti les présidents de groupes
parlementaires et les présidents
d'assemblée afin de faire un point sur
la situation liée à l'épidémie
françois tisca beach
le ministre de la santé l'a annoncé ce
mercredi soir lors d'un point presse
la france a enregistré son huitième cas
de coronavirus s'il s'agit de l'épousé
du patient
actuellement hospitalisés à annecy et la
détection systématique du virus a permis
d'identifier que cette épouse du
patients hospitalisés à annecy était
positive pour le coronavirus son état de
santé n'est pas inquiétant
mais elle est évidemment hospitalisés et
isoler au même titre que les autres
malades
olivier ferrand a par ailleurs précisé
qu'il n'y a toujours pas d'épidémie en
france
dans la matinée les autorités françaises
ont annoncé le premier mort à cause du
virus
l'homme âgé de 60 ans était hospitalisé
à l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris
originaire de l'oise il ne s'était pas
rendue dans une zone d'exposition
professeur de technologie dans un
collège de crépy en valois la préfecture
écartent tout risque de contagion pour
ses élèves et ses collègues dès lors
qu'il a été prise en charge et bien n'a
plus été en contact à partir du 10
février avec des élèves ou avec des
parents d'élèves des collègues
enseignants
donc ce risque est écarté et puis nous
sommes le 26 février le de ce délai de
14 jours personne ne s'étant signalé
comme ayant des symptômes qui pourraient
être assimilées à une contagion par le
coran la virus et bien il ya tout lieu
de penser qu'il n'ya plus de personnes
contaminées
les hôpitaux se prépare comme ici à
l'institut méditerranéen fiction de
marseille chercheurs médecins et
laborantins sont sur le pied de guerre
pour réagir face à une éventuelle
pandémie aussi s'avérait qu'un patient
soit porteur du corona chinois ou en cas
de patients qui présentent une forme
sévère d'infection qui justifie son
hospitalisation
eh bien il est transféré immédiatement
au troisième étage de lille a chuté dans
le service de maladies infectieuses où
il sera admis par l'intermédiaire d'un
ascenseur dédié donc il ne croisera pas
à ce patient aucun soignant ni aucun
autre patient et il sera donc installée
dans une chambre des pressions dans
cette chambre est bien du liseron
administrer les soins éventuellement
l'administration de chloroquine ci
s'avère que c'est un virus pour nagl
chinois ou d'autres traitements il se
passera dans cette chambre jusqu'à ce
qu'ils soient jugés non contagieux à
nice situe à moins de 50 kilomètres de
la frontière italienne
la ville a décidé d'annuler les derniers
jours du carnaval à titre préventif
il devait se dérouler jusqu'à samedi et
selon barbara cui infirmière à l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris et membre du
collectif intérieur gens s'il faudrait
davantage informés les premiers
cerné le personnel hospitalier on écoute
sur ce virus spécifique en france on a
quand même aujourd'hui une sorte de un
manque de fluidité des informations
les équipes sont vigilantes et sont
souvent en attente et réclame le
transfert des informations parce que
tout ce qui décide au niveau ministériel
n'est pas forcément encore à ce jour
arriver jusqu'aux au personnel de
terrain les consignes on a fait un bilan
au niveau national aujourd'hui elles
sont vraiment très disparate entre les
les services qui sont les hôpitaux
centres pour certaines régions
aujourd'hui sont au nombre de 138 ils
ont été augmentés
on imagine bien que c'est pas à
l'ensemble des hôpitaux qui sont
mobilisés donc les consignes sont
différentes pour tout le monde
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est ça reste
surtout le bon sens des soignants on n'a
pas plus d'informations
donc c'est on se protège avec les
masques ffp2 pour pouvoir
on ne peut pas savoir donc le diagnostic
n'a pas été validé au niveau des
laboratoires si la personne est infectée
ou non donc à ce jour il va falloir
anticiper et se protéger au delà de ce
qui sera réel dans les faits et pour le
professeur yves buisson membre de
l'académie nationale de médecine il y à
un bien un profil de patients à risque
écoutez le il faut rappeler que la
majorité des infections dues à ce
coronavirus sont soit bénigne soit peu
grave
pas plus qu'une grippe normale mais il y
a effectivement surtout chez les
personnes qui sont soient âgées soient
porteuses d'une maladie chronique
il ya des formes très sévères effets
mortels et l'atteinte pulmonaire qu'on
appelle le syndrome de détresse
respiratoire aiguë qui entraîne souvent
une défaillance multiviscérale c'est à
dire que leurs reins le foie
ne cessent de fonctionner et bien c'est
une conséquence malheureusement de ses
formes graves et qui mène au décès plus
on est âgé et moins se défend
efficacement le système immunitaire suse
et la défense de l'organisme contre
l'infection est moins efficace
et puis il y a les maladies associées
les traitement au long cours
un des traitements notamment les
traitements immunosuppresseurs qui
peuvent favoriser des formes graves
donc les patients cancéreux les patients
qui sont atteintes de pathologies
complexes chroniques seront bien entendu
beaucoup plus à risque d'être victime
d'une forme grave
réunion au sommet à vienne autour du
nucléaire iranien outre l'iran la france
le royaume uni l'allemagne la chine et
la russie ont participé à cette
rencontre
objectif préserver la corde 2015 et ce
malgré le retrait de washington en 2018
à téhéran ces cartes progressivement de
cet accord en réponse aux sanctions qui
lui sont imposées l'iran réclame le
respect de tous les accords et de toutes
les parties signent hante
nous sommes toujours ouverts à toute
initiative susceptible de garantir à
l'iran les dividendes du disciple way et
nous sommes tout à fait disposés à
annuler les mesures que nous avons
prises jusqu'à présent
en contrepartie du respect des
engagements de l'autre partie au titre
du dc bio et tous les autres
participants audi bio et ont confirmé
une fois de plus l'importance de cet
accord et soutiennent cet accord et
leurs efforts leur volonté de protéger
cet accord est de s'assurer que l'accord
le disciple e et reste en vie le 14
juillet 2015 un accord historique était
conclue avec l'objectif de limiter le
nucléaire iranien
côté américain barack obama en est l
signataires mais que contient-il et
pourquoi dérange-t-il temps donald trump
les précisions de grâce d'ailleurs
un accord qui rassemble les états unis
l'union européenne dont le royaume uni
l'allemagne et la france ainsi que la
chine la russie et l'iran avant que le
texte soit paraphé les négociations ont
duré près de 21 mois
son objectif empêcher téhéran de se
doter de la bombe atomique
mais pourquoi cet accord en 1974 le pays
s'engage à le fabriquer ni à se procurer
la bombe atomique
en signant un traité de
non-prolifération en 1979 quand
l'ayatollah khomeini prend le pouvoir et
instaure la révolution islamique
les puissances occidentales ne sont plus
perçus d'un très bon oeil du côté de
téhéran le 4 novembre de cette même
année
une prise d'otages menée par des
étudiants iraniens débute à l'ambassade
des états unis
52 personnes sont concernées dont des
diplomates et des civils la prise
d'otage dur à 444 jours
la riposte des états unis ne se fait pas
attendre 12 milliards d'actifs iranien
jeudi dans la foulée sans oublier de
nombreux autres sanctions dont un
embargo sur les armes en 1995
au niveau international on commence à se
pencher sur le cas de téhéran en 2000
agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique découvre deux sites nucléaires
iraniens ce secret malgré de nombreux
avertissements la république islamique
ne tremble pas l'union européenne et
l'onu infligent les premières sanctions
économiques en 2006 en 2013 le modéré
hassan rohani prend les rênes du pays
c'est grâce à lui que la situation
s'apaise et permet deux ans plus tard de
parvenir à l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien
quelles obligations contient-il l'iran
s'engage à diviser par deux le nombre de
ses sites à ne pas construire de
nouvelles infrastructures destinées à
l'enrichissement d'uranium pendant dix
ans et à ne pas enrichir d'uranium à
plus de 3 67%
installation de nathan ce sera le seul
site d'enrichissement d'uranium du pays
à rester en fonctionnement mais en 2017
donald 30 arrive à la maison blanche
l'année suivante il affirme avoir la
preuve que téhéran continue de
développer l'armé nucléaire
rôtir les états unis de l'accord et
sanctionne immédiatement la république
islamique
plus de transactions financières ni
d'importation pour couronner le tout
washington place 50 banques iraniennes
sur une liste noire
commence alors un bras de fer qui
perdure jusqu'à aujourd'hui et pour
nasser et et m'a dit journaliste à rfi
nous sommes au tout début d'un processus
dont le résultat demeure très incertain
ces discussions rappelons-le au ont eu
lieu au niveau des directeurs des
ministères des affaires étrangères des
pays aux deux pays signataires de ces
accords
et puis il n'ya pas une date butoir donc
on est au début d'un processus dont le
résultat est encore incertain cet accord
nucléaire ni c'est pas dans le fait même
si tous les signataires et insistent sur
le fait qu'ils veulent toujours gardé
leurs engagements par rapport à cet
accord les oraux temps les chinois et
les rousses compris et craint de plus en
plus que par cette mise en cause c'est
réciproque par les américains et les
iraniens
il y aura pas la cour du cul nucléaire
donc le traité de non-prolifération sera
finalement mise en cause qui est un coup
grave en fait aux équilibres à
l'équilibré mondial et que finalement il
y aurait un risque d'affrontement en
l'occurrence entre les américains et les
iraniens dans une région qui est déjà
déchiré par les guerres interminables
sans nom
moscou toujours dans le viseur des états
unis et de hauts responsables démocrates
ont demandé à ce que l'administration
trump impose de nouvelles sanctions
contre la russie en cause la tentative
présumée d'ingérence russe annoncé par
le renseignement américain aux membres
du congrès explications d'antoine
claireaux notre correspondant à moscou
trois sénateurs démocrates ont écrit au
secrétaire d'état mike p o et au
secrétaire au trésor stephen low chine
pour exiger que l'administration trump
impose immédiatement et avec force des
sanctions contre le gouvernement et les
citoyens russes soupçonnés d'implication
dans la supposée ingérence électorale
l'administration trump a la possibilité
d'imposer des sanctions pour l'ingérence
dans nos élections
elle n'a pas besoin de nouveaux outils
législatifs ou d'approbation
notre message est clair secrétaire
minchin imposer des sanctions
immédiatement faire quoi que ce soit 2 -
reviendrait à vous dédouaner de votre
responsabilité de protection et de
défense des états unis envers cette
grave menace contre notre sécurité
nationale et contre l'intégrité de notre
processus électoral et les trois élus
signataires ne sont pas les premiers
venus
chuck schaeffer est le leader de la
minorité démocrate au sénat tandis que
bob menendez et sherrod brown sont
respectivement charge des comités
sénatoriaux des relations étrangères et
bancaire les qu'elle supervise la
politique de sanctions quant à la
réaction de moscou à l'envoi de cette
lettre elle n'a pas tardé
l'ambassade de russie aux etats-unis
exprime sa profonde préoccupation face à
la tournure des spéculations sur l'
ingérence présumée de la russie dans les
élections américaines
il est particulièrement frappant de voir
comment les forces politiques à
washington
exploite ce mythe pour en tirer un gain
politique faire des allégations non
liées à la russie totalement infondées
et fictive devient une bien mauvaise
tradition politique aux etats unis
lorsqu'il n'ya pas suffisamment
d'arguments lorsqu'il n'ya pas
suffisamment d'outils pour mener un
combat politique sur le plan domestique
ont fait appel à ce facteur russe c'est
une triste réalité à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés depuis de nombreuses
années mais au fait que contient ce
brief du renseignement américain on y
apprend via les médias
d'outre-atlantique com
ce coup semble se livrer à des campagnes
de désinformation et de propagande pour
aider à la fois le favori pour
l'investiture démocrate bernie sanders
mais aussi le président sortant donald
trump qui entend bien se faire réélire
au mois de novembre
récit qui repose entièrement sur des
sources anonymes non vérifiables et qui
est malheureusement amené à se répéter
selon le porte-parole du kremlin il
s'agit là de nouveaux messages
paranoïaque qui malheureusement seront
de plus en plus nombreux à la proche des
élections
bien sûr cela n'a rien à voir avec la
vérité alors que la soi-disant ingérence
russe est de nouveau bondi aux états
unis à la proche de la présidentielle
moscou estime que cette pseudo menace de
l'extérieur est instrumentalisée à des
fins de politique intérieure
et selon ben swan journaliste
d'investigation américain le spectre
russe est un épouvantail pour faire
trembler les électeurs un épouvantail
qui ne fonctionne pas si bien que ça
d'ailleurs
je pense effectivement qu'il réveille
les fantômes du passé et du présent
en effet c'est vraiment un fantôme qui
l'ont créé de toutes pièces
c'est une terminologie autour de l'art
aussi une forme d'épouvantail selon
lequel la russie serait une grande
menace à l'époque de la guerre froide
c'était une menace nucléaire mais ce
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
donc lorsqu'on demande aujourd'hui aux
gens quelle est la menace représentée
par la russie pour les états unis ne
peuvent pas expliquer ne savent pas ce
que c'est
il ya beaucoup de menaces dans le monde
entier notamment par exemple d'autres
grandes puissances telles que la chine
est également au niveau militaire ainsi
qu économique mais la russie n'est pas
du tout au même niveau donc la
terminologie utilisée qui est réapparu
lors du débat démocrate s'est dit hier
la première question du débat ça
pressait à bernie sanders et la riposte
michael bloomberg était que c'est les
russes qui voulaient que banny thunder
remporte les élections
donc cette terminologie tourner et très
péjorative autour des russes mais pour
la plupart des américains lorsqu'on leur
demande ce qui fait 5h avec la russie
ils ne peuvent pas expliquer parce
qu'ils savent juste que c'est mal en
france les avocats maintiennent la
pression sur le gouvernement concernant
la réforme des retraites ils ont
manifesté devant l'assemblée nationale
pour dénoncer la modification de leur
régime de retraite et l'absence d'
écoute du ministère de la justice
les robes noires point paix le
doublement de leurs cotisations et
craignent de voir un grand nombre de
cabinets mettre la clé sous la porte
à l'assemblée nationale et qui a voté
aujourd'hui au dixième jour des débats
avec pour objectif un dispositif de
solidarité pour les petits cabinets
d'avocats dans le cadre du passage au
système universel une mesure jugée pas à
la hauteur par l'opposition je vous
propose d'en écouter quelques-uns
protestent contre le projet de loi de
réforme des retraites parce que ce
projet va faire que la moitié des
cabinets vont fermer en seine saint
denis c'est plus de la moitié des
cabinets qui vont fermer parce que le
gouvernement va doubler nos cotisations
etc cette réforme des retraites
le doublement de nos cotisations
implique que tous les avocats qui
s'occupe notamment des personnes les
plus faibles des plus démunis et qui ont
donc des revenus les plus faibles aussi
vont devoir fermer leurs cabinets et les
justiciables encore une fois les plus
les plus fragiles qui vont se trouver
pénaliser outre les avocats c'est pas
simplement une manifestation
corporatiste des avocats c'est aussi
pour une certaine idée de la justice du
service public de la justice auxquelles
les avocats concours
que nous manifestons c'est une
profession dont maintenant la france
s'aperçoit parce que jusqu'à présent on
vivait sur l'idée un peu surfaite d'une
profession nantis et la profession
d'avocat est la profession la plus
pauvre du droit l amour la majorité des
avocats perçoivent un revenu moyen de
40000 euros par an sur des exercices
totalement libéraux donc à leur charge
et ne n'a pas du tout les clés les
capacités financières de résister à un
doublement des charges et à une
réduction de l'art de l'art de la
retraite future
les avocats également mobilisés ce soir
à versailles le rendez vous a été donné
devant la cour d'appel pour un trajet
illuminé aux flambeaux faut le point
versailles avec notre reporter lille a
famous les avocats maintiennent le cap
ils étaient une centaine à s'être donnés
rendez vous devant la cour d'appel de
versailles pour une marche aux flambeaux
en direction du château de versailles
et oui semaines déjà qui la défendent
bec et ongles leur régime autonome
qu'ils estimaient être menacée par cette
réforme je vous propose de les écouter
l'idée c'est pas forcément de déranger
c'est d'être vu l'idée c'est de que les
gens sachent que quelles sont nos
revendications et que nos revendications
ne sont pas celles de nantis qui protège
une espèce de trésor de guerre
on entend ça à longueur de journée c'est
insupportable notre combat n'est pas
celui là nous avons un régime
indépendant depuis
grosso modo le début des années 50 on
pourrait peut-être nous laisser
tranquilles on a réussi on a on a on a
réglé ce régime de manière autonome de
manière satisfaisante par les avocats et
pour les avocats
on a envie de dire au gouvernement
aujourd'hui au parlement
laissez nous tranquilles avec notre
régime de retraite qui ne coûte rien à
personne et rapporte c'est le principe
de notre profession c'est notre
engagement d'avocats on ne cède pas
jusqu'au bout nous menons le combat et
tant que le gouvernement n'aura pas
compris que c'est une impasse de
conduire c'est le projet de réforme de
la caisse autonome des avocats nous
poursuivrons la lutte la solidarité les
avocats nous n'avons pas de leçons à
recevoir à ce niveau là car notre
profession depuis la nuit des temps aide
les plus impécunieux
dans le cadre de toutes les permanences
que nous effectuions et puis surtout
notre caisse de retraite autonome
reverse chaque année 100 millions au
régime général aux autres caisses
déficitaires
ils ont prévu dans les jours à venir des
actions au niveau local mais aussi
national et tous ceux avec qui nous
avons parlé aujourd'hui nous ont dit
qu'ils ne voulaient pas de modification
de ce projet mais tout simplement le
retrait pur et simple de la réforme des
retraites
les résultats sont tombés en fin
d'après-midi rt france ne sera pas mise
en demeure une seconde fois par le csa à
ce matin les représentants de notre
chaîne ont été reçus en audience est
entendu par le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel est cette procédure de
sanction s'est ouverte suite à la
diffusion d'un sujet en avril 2019
dans ce sujet il est fait état de
déclarations d'un général russe à propos
de la syrie
pour rappel le rapporteur indépendant
auprès du csa avait préconisé de ne pas
sanctionner un autre média et pour
maître david koubbi est l'un des avocats
de rt france les charges retenues contre
la chaîne n'était pas audible et j'ai eu
l'occasion de plaider ce matin pour le
compte de votre chaîne c'était le procès
du selon puisque vos journalistes
disaient selon un général russe
voici ce qui a été dit toutes les
chaînes dit selon washington selon
johnson selon poutine selon trump selon
macro donc on ne peut pas faire le
procès du selon vous comprenez ça n'est
pas audible puisque vous citez la
personnalité qui qui en parlent à les
enjeux étaient cruciaux les enjeux
étaient de première importance puisque
les sanctions pouvant être prononcée
pouvait pouvait aller très clairement
jusqu'à
la rupture de la convention qui lie la
chaîne arte france avec le csa c'est à
dire au delà
l'arrêt de la diffusion troisième jour
de procès pour julian assange devant la
justice britannique le fondateur de
wikileaks s'est plaint ce mercredi
d'avoir des échanges pas assez privé
avec ses avocats
une sortie vite interrompue par la juge
qui a ordonné une courte pause un long
droit décidé de donner suite ou non à la
demande américaine d'extradition du
lanceur d'alerté australien il est
poursuivi pour espionnage et piratage
informatique et risque jusqu'à 60 75 ans
de prison on écoute l'une de ses
avocates
l'accusation a ouvert le dossier en
citant une déclaration du journal the
guardian en 2011 qui prenait ses
distances et condamné julian assange
pour avoir publié les câbles
diplomatiques
cela dit cette accusation ne vaut pas
car c'est le journaliste du guardian qui
a divulgué le mot de passe lui même je
pense donc qu'il est vraiment important
de prendre note enfin de tenir compte de
la chronologie qui a été présenté
aujourd'hui au tribunal
julian assange a effectivement pris des
mesures de sécurité importantes et
responsables pour essayer de protéger
ces documents et selon stéphanie gibeau
lanceuse d'alert certains risquent bien
pire que des menaces écoutez la le
procès assange catalyse la problématique
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où on
se lève à partir du moment où on parle
à partir du moment où on dit la vérité
on doit être exécuté quelle que soit la
lettre
quel que soit le sujet alors comment
wikileaks qui est une publication qui
n'a fait que donner des informations
d'intérêt général et qui sont
effectivement très dommageable pour nos
états étant donné ce qui nous était
cachée on comprend que le gouvernement
américain les gouvernements américain et
pu lui en vouloir beaucoup
maintenant il s'agit du combat pour la
vérité il s'agit du combat aussi et des
droits de l'homme
est ce que ceux qui disent la vérité
doivent être plus condamnés que ceux qui
assassinent ce qui manque ce qui trompe
ce qu'ils émanent le fisc etc etc
et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment la société civile qui doit elle
sans parler de ces sujets puisqu'on a vu
que tous ceux qui étaient censés nous
soutenir notamment nos hommes politiques
notamment les associations notamment
mais il ya eu absolument personne donc
merci à tous ceux qui se mobilisent et
je pense que ce n'est que le début d'une
mobilisation à l'international le bilan
s'alourdit en inde plus de 20 morts et
200 blessés dans les violences inter
communautaires qui frappe new delhi
depuis dimanche de nombreux quartiers de
la capitale sur le théâtre de scènes de
guérilla urbaine
en cause une loi controversée sur la
citoyenneté est jugée discriminatoire
pour les musulmans les détails avec
solène gaudin et rania berrada scènes de
guérilla à peine une dizaine de
kilomètres du centre de new delhi depuis
trois jours cette partie de la capitale
indienne est le théâtre de violents
affrontements
ce qui était au départ des
manifestations contre une loi sur la
citoyenneté jugé discriminatoire s'est
transformée en lutte armée entre
nationalistes hindous et musulmans
véhicules magasins et maisons incendiées
une situation qui pousse les habitants à
fuir craignant pour leur vie
les hôtels ferment les usines ferment
qu'allons nous faire
les gens m'appellent de mon village ils
sont tous inquiets
qu'est ce qu'on va faire il vaut mieux
partir que rester ici pourquoi
voudrions-nous mourir et si les gens
s'entretuent des balles pleuvent
j'ai vu des affrontements dans le
quartier depuis ce matin et je quitte la
maison pour cela et une population qui
dénonce l'inaction des forces de l'ordre
depuis hier nous demandons à la police
d'appliquer un couvre-feu d'envoyer des
renforts mais personne n'est venu
il n'y a que trois policiers on a appelé
la police plusieurs fois depuis chang
bague les gens scandaient gloire au
seigneur ram est rentré dans le quartier
mais la police ne nous a pas du tout
aidé pour tenter de contenir
l'embrasement un couvre-feu a été imposé
dans ses quartiers depuis hier soir le
premier ministre n'a rien drame audi a
appelé au calme ce matin sur twitter la
paix et l'harmonie sont au coeur de
notre philosophie
j'invite mes soeurs et frères de délier
à maintenir la paix et la fraternité en
tout temps il est important qu'il y ait
calme et que la normalité soit rétabli
ou plutôt parmi les responsables indiens
des voix s'élèvent pour condamner la
passivité des autorités
la présidente du parti du congrès sonia
gandhi réclament la démission du
ministre de l'intérieur et c'est la fin
de cette édition merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain point sur l'actualité de demain
7h heure française
excellente soirée sur rt france
[Musique]
est ce qu'on peut parler de fracture
entre le nord de l'europe et le sud
on sait qu'il ya une fracture on sait
qu'il ya des pays qui ont été mal géré
vous avez deux pays de la zone euro et
donc les pays du sud qui n'ont pas
encore retrouvé leur niveau de richesse
d'avant la crise vous avez la grèce et
aussi lithâm ans malgré tout les aides
qu'on a pu avoir au niveau de la zone
euro n'a pas réussi à sortir de la crise
c'est à dire qu'on vous parle de la
baisse du chômage au portugal ou en
espagne
en fait c'est simplement que vous avez
une grosse partie de la population et
des jeunes sont partis le drame c'est
que tous ces pays a eu notamment chez
nous en france des publics a augmenté
mais n'a pas généré 350 je ne sais pas
qui est la locomotive de l'europe en
tout cas ne croyez pas que ce soit la
france
j'ai entendu parler de wikileaks et de
julian assange pour la première fois
quand j'ai vu les images filmées depuis
l'hélicoptère en irak continue à tirer
et je pense qu'il ya des gens dans
l'armée américaine qui ne lui ont jamais
pardonné
je ne suis pas pour la peine de mort et
puisque je ne suis pas pour la peine de
mort
il n'a qu'une chose à faire abattre ce
fils de [ __ ] illégalement et oasis et
est historique il n'est pas d'avoir un
journaliste indépendant
un type avec son ordinateur révélant des
crimes de guerre
un large public l'idée de développer une
boîte de dépôts numériques anonyme en
lien avec le média qu'est wikileaks
c'est une vraie nouveauté est sauf
[Musique]